grande ville quand il se connecte n est
pas seulement d'elle même elle parle
aussi de comment créer un cercle
vertueux avec les villes des alentours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain d'actualité toujours dominé par
la crise du coronavirus en france et
notamment la phase 2 du déconfinement
présenté aujourd'hui voici les titres
la disparition de la limitation des 100
km réouverture des restaurants et bars à
partir du 2 juin partout en zone verte
enterra seulement en zone orange
réouverture progressive des collèges et
lycées en zone orange annulation du bas
chorale de français c'est en substance
ce qu'il faut retenir de cette phase 2
du déconfinement présentait donc cet
après midi par edouard philippe qui
salue une situation fruit du bon travail
de tous les soignants un style de la
rigueur de tous les français
la troisième phase ce sera pour le 22
juin une relance à 750 milliards d'euros
pour l'union européenne la commission de
bruxelles a présenté son plan pour
répondre à la crise du corps des virus
il fait la part belle aux subventions et
favorise les pays les plus touchés comme
l'italie et l'espagne
ce plan largement soutenue par la france
et l'allemagne peut-il remporter
l'adhésion des plus réfractaires comme
les pays-bas ou l'autriche est il à la
hauteur de la récession historique qui
nous attend ce sera l'objet de la
chronique et au de jacques sapir ce soir
les
plus d'une heure d'allocutions donc pour
le premier ministre entouré des
ministres de l'éducation et de la santé
pour présenter cette phase 2 du
déconfinement nous sommes en direct
depuis matignon avec notre reporter
thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas vous avez
évidemment suivi cette allocution que
peut-on retenir de ce long discours et
de ces mesures a présenté par edouard
fini
les nouvelles sont bonnes c'est l'une
des premières phrases qu'à prononcer
edouard philippe lors de son allocution
il a expliqué que la propagation du
virus était sous contrôle et c'est pour
cette raison que cette deuxième phase du
déconfinement vois un certain nombre de
règles s'assouplir l'une des plus
emblématique d'entre elles c'est la
règle des 100 km la restriction de
déplacement au delà de 100 km sauf motif
impérieux cette règle est supprimée elle
n'avait plus de raison d'être explique
le premier ministre
en france comme je l'expliquais même si
certains déplacement nécessite encore
une vigilance importante
la tension est globalement moindre qu'au
début du déconfinement la mesure
d'interdiction de déplacement de plus de
100 km a été très utile durant ces trois
dernières semaines pour limiter la
propagation du virus
elle a été bien respecté par les
français je les en remercie mais
aujourd'hui avec la pression qui a
baissé
cette mesure n'a plus de justification à
compter du 2 juin
il est donc mis fin à l'interdiction de
déplacement de plus de 100 kilomètres de
chez soi autres grandes annonces du
premier ministre elle concerne la carte
du déconfinement il n'y a plus de
département en zone rouge l'ensemble du
territoire et en zone verte à
l'exception notable des départements de
la région ile de france ainsi que la
guyane et mayotte et le fait que ces
départements soit classé en zone orange
et bien cela a un impact sur
l'assouplissement des règles
exemple avec la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants ils pourront rouvrir sur
l'ensemble du territoire à partir du 2
juin prochain mais dans les zones
oranges seulement les terrasses de
seebach et de ses restaurants pourront
accueillir des clients
en revanche les parcs les jardins et les
plages pourrait ouvrir sur l'ensemble
territoire en ce qui concerne les
collèges là encore différenciation entre
les zones vertes et les zones oranges
dans les zones vertes l'ensemble des
collèges pourra rouvrir de façon
complète réouverture partielle seulement
dans les zones oranges et puis pour les
lycées ce sera une ouverture progressive
on a noté également que l'oral de
français pour l'épreuve du baccalauréat
se fera sur la base du contrôle continu
autre exemple de cette différenciation
entre zone verte et jaune orangé bien
cela concerne les centres de les espaces
de loisirs et de pratiques sportives le
2 juin les salles de spectacle les
gymnases ou encore les piscines pourront
rouvrir sur l'ensemble des zones vertes
mais n'est pas encore dans les zones
oranges pour orange il faudra attendre
la date du 22 juin la date du 22 juin
c'est aussi celle qui a été choisie pour
la réouverture totale cette fois des
cinémas sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour justifier cet assouplissement des
règles edouard philippe a bien sûr
avancer les arguments de la propagation
du virus qui est plus faible que la plus
être par le passé mais il ya aussi une
urgence économique une récession
historique qui a frappé le pays ce sont
ses mots je propose d'écouter edouard
philippe qui parle des chiffres du
chômage qui sont parues aujourd'hui les
chiffres présentés par pôle emploi ce
matin la teste essonne d'urgence le
nombre de personnes inscrites à pôle
emploi qui n'ont pas travaillé du tout
en avril a augmenté de plus de 800
milles par rapport à mars
c'est malheureusement historique malgré
cet assouplissement généralisée des
mesures sanitaires edouard philippe
appelle encore évidemment à la vigilance
de tous il avec par exemple rappelé la
mise en service prochainement de
l'application stop qu'ovide pour
retracer les contacts entre les
personnes malades par le virus du covin
il a également appelé les français à
faire preuve d'un esprit de
responsabilité et prochaine étape
maintenant pour ceux des compliments ce
sera le 22 juin pour la troisième phase
de ceux des confirmands merci thomas
bonnet pour toutes ces précisions
et pour en parler côté réactions nous
sommes avec danièle obono député la
france insoumise de la dix septième
circonscription de paris
en direct par téléphone bonsoir danièle
obono tout en vert donc excepté mayotte
guyane et l ile de france edouard
philippe qui salue l'attitude des
français des soignants une fois n'est
pas coutume avez vous envie de saluer la
stratégie du gouvernement ce soir est
coupée la stratégie on va voir comment
elles se déploient dans cette deuxième
phase pour le moment qui est sûre on va
être d'accord avec le premier ministre
sur le fait que c'est effectivement
grâce à l'implication des soignants leur
engagement sans faille et bien sûr cela
mobilisation de la population qui a
assuré la réussite du confinement que
cette deuxième phase est possible et
donc il voulait on s'accordera sur ce
constat pour ce qui est de la stratégie
du gouvernement il ya encore beaucoup de
questionnements sur les moyens qui sont
mis en oeuvre on fait que par exemple
sur la question des écoles dans l'île de
france par exemple moins de deux élèves
sur dix ont repris l'école parce que les
moyens pour garantir la sécurité
sanitaire ne sont pas réunies dans une
majorité d'établissements scolaires et
c'est le résultat du manque de
planification du manque de concertation
avec les personnels de l'éducation
nationale qui n'ont pas du tout était
impliqué dans la réflexion sur cette
réouverture des écoles et je crois que
la deuxième phase avec la la relance
économique doit être aussi planifié de
cette manière là c'est à dire avec
discussions dans les secteurs sur la
manière dont les garanties sanitaires
les protection sanitaire et c'était
quand même ça la priorité puisse être
assurée à la fois dans les commerces
pour les salariés elle est ouverte
puisque dans ce qu'ils vont nous on fait
des trucs qui vont être aussi qu'ils
vont reprendre du travail sur six est
donc il faut que leur sécurité soit 100
de l'artiste ou celle des délais des
clients et des clients
et donc on va voir comment tout cela tu
déploies mais parme était quand même que
l'on appelle les erreurs les retards et
le manque ni compris jusqu'à présent
d'un certain nombre d'éléments coréen
mais cruciaux que ce soit la question
des pet ou des mac pour que nous
restions en tout cas extrêmement
vigilants et prudents quand de croix la
population les villes cas présent et qui
a permis cette deuxième phase en tout
cas effectivement ce déconfinement le
sens s'accélère à la faveur de bons
chiffres même si on nous le rappelle
tout le temps et évidemment il faut
rester prudents et bars et restaurants
qui rouvre totalement en zone verte
uniquement les terrasses en zone orange
dont l'ile-de-france ça vous inspire
quoi c'est un petit peu la double peine
peut être un pour les restaurateurs
d'ile-de-france qui ont déjà subi la
crise des gilet jaune qui subissent
maintenant voilà cette discrimination
peut être obligatoire mais
discrimination quand même tout le monde
n'a pas une terrasse
quelle est votre réaction écoutez c'est
une situation extrêmement difficile
effectivement pour énormément de
commerce de travail à travers les
indépendants de professions libérales et
bien sûr qu'il faut que l'état joue tout
son rôle de protection économique
il y a eu des fonds qui ont été mis en
oeuvre pour indemniser la famille pour
la passion il faut que ces fonds soient
prolongées et que pour sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais en particulier dans
l'est dans les territoires qu'ils vont
avoir un déconfinement économique plus
progressif et plus lents il faut assurer
effectivement l'indemnisation de tous
les commerces qui ne pourront pas ouvrir
ou pour qui l'ouverture mais ces titres
à un investissement important et c'est
là où le rôle de la puissance publique
est primordiale et je crois que que ce
soit sur la libère la diversion de la
part d'exploitation que ce soit sur le
chômage partiel qui doit être assurée
jusqu'au bout et au plus haut plus haut
niveau possible
et puis plus largement je crois que
l'enjeu
et on parle de roland économique il faut
quelqu'un crie en fait dans une
véritable traque pays
on est dans un moment où toutes les
mesures qu'on met en sommes aujourd'hui
y compris au niveau économique vont
déterminer la suite vont déterminer la
direction vers laquelle on va s'orienter
pour la suite et pour la relance
économique
oui pour les commerces pour les
activités là il faut que l'état joue un
rôle de stratège et puis permet de cette
relance l'art dans le sens de ce que
nous on croit être nécessaire que la
mesure d'allouer aux colonies oui et
doré ce secteur-là
il ya énormément d'emplois qui qui
peuvent être créées qui doivent être
créées qui vont soutenir y compris la
demande qui permettra au commerce orac
raté en fait les les pertes nikki qui
sont importantes effectivement un autre
modèle mono sinon on va pas réussi à
vous poser la troisième question et doit
finir dans son ensemble appel à la
responsabilité on ne peut pas courir le
risque de la désinvolture les
rassemblements qu'une dix personnes sont
proscrits dans les endroits publics on a
vu ces derniers jours les anars je m'en
commander les matchs sauvage de football
à strasbourg dans l'essonne quelle est
votre réaction que faut-il comment
faut-il traiter justement ces personnes
qui enfreignent d'une certaine manière
les interdictions qui a rappelé quand
même un peu s'il ya des personnes qui
ont fait preuve de désinvolture c'est
d'abord le gouvernement en premier lieu
au début de cette épidémie et y compris
je les dis au début mais rappelons le il
nous n'avons pu arriver à une situation
où le niveau de circulation du virus a
été considérablement réduite est parti
d'une mobilisation de la population qui
a respecté dans son camion intégralité
le confinement et quand ce n'était pas
dans l'inspecteur c'était pour un
certain nombre de raisons y compris pour
les pour les personnels et les salariés
qui devait être sur site et cetera ou
qu'ils étaient obligés d'y être donc
franchement je ne crois pas que ce soit
là même la meilleure manière de de poser
la question rappelons que le confinement
et la restriction des libertés parce
qu'on est quand même encore dans l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui donne des
pouvoirs exorbitants à l'exécutif qui a
donné les preuves y compris qu de ces
manquements et des abus qui peuvent
avoir lieu dans ce genre de cas et qui
restent
énormément les droits et des libertés je
crois que les nantais les fontaines
toute la population ont fait preuve de
six livres qu'on ferait beaucoup plus
que le gouvernement y compris peuvent
avoir les moyens toujours de ta
protection
je vous rappelle que les masques quand
il tombe victoires ne sont pas
systématiquement gratuit ce que ce que
doit être le cas et le poids réel mois
que la population saura faire y compris
mieux que le gouvernement pour assurer
la protection des dents et des lunes
aider d'autres merveilles soit le
gouvernement doit assurer les moyens de
cette protection
que ce soit au niveau sanitaire mais
également sociales et économiques merci
daniel logos de n'avoir été avec nous
pour réagir à ces annonces d'edouard
philippe edouard fini qui a également
annoncé la réouverture des restaurants
et des bars sont conditions pour les
régions orange rose délecter compte tenu
de l'évolution de la crise sanitaire les
restaurants bars et cafés pourront
ouvrir dans tous les départements à
partir du 2 juin mais ils ouvriront avec
des restrictions temporaires dans ceux
qui se trouvent dans les zones oranges
là où une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire les personnes qui ont choisi
de dîner ou de déjeuner ensemble
pourront s'asseoir à la même table dans
la limite d'une capacité maximale de 10
par table mais il devrait y avoir une
distance minimale d'un mètre entre les
tables de sacs groupe dans les
départements qui font l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière les départements
de l'île de france
mayotte et la guyane seuls les terrasses
des cafés et des bars et des restaurants
pourront ouvrir au 2 juin
les offres réouverture dans des cafés et
des restaurants à partir du 2 juin
véritable soulagement forcément pour les
restaurateurs c'est le cas notamment à
bordeaux écouter ça fait plaisir
vingtaine de salles après un peu des
mois un peu dur
et puis on est content de pouvoir
trouver le client est
le savoir qu'on va pouvoir travailler là
condition que son twitter
acceptable et la situation aurait
organise les tables rondes et des
marquages au sol pour les clients on
condamne une partie des toilettes
les urinoirs on a beaucoup de
l'affichage qui sont regardés sur les
murs et ce après ça on voit que sur eux
mêmes sur l'emporter à le déconfinement
là qu'on aille à partir du 11 mai
c'était pas non plus
le groupe a donc
je pense que les gens avec le soleil on
est tranquille et cette réaction en
direct à présent pour en parler nous
sommes avec pascal mousset président
génie à paris ile de france je précise
que le groupement national des
indépendants est le premier syndicat
hôtels et restaurants en région
parisienne le deuxième au niveau
national également direct avec nous en
direct de calvi et jean pierre pinelli
vice président du cercle des grandes
maisons corses bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france pour réagir donc à ces annonces
d'edouard philippe pascal mousset bonne
nouvelle donc pour la zone verte un qui
va pouvoir ouvrir sans fin on en parlera
évidemment des restrictions mais a
priori sans condition en revanche la
zone orange c'est moins évident
puisqu'il faudrait être doté d'une
terrasse ce soir qu'est ce qui prédomine
chez vous comme état d'esprit peut-on de
soulagement la satisfaction parce que
réouvrir pour nous c'est retrouver nos
clients remettent des collaborateurs au
travail donc ça va dans le bon sens et
cette situation depuis le 15 mars
devenait intenable sur le plan humain
économique et de couper notre métier
notre passion ça devenait compliqué
maintenant on est bien conscient que
c'est une demi-mesure on aurait espéré
comme nos collègues de province passer
au vert et ré ouvrir plus largement
aujourd'hui beaucoup de restaurateurs ne
dispose pas de terrasse et je tiens à
préciser notamment pour la région de
français pour paris que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui les conditions
administratives d'extension de nos
terrasses et donc aucun restaurateurs ne
peut aujourd'hui s'adresser à la mairie
et dire je souhaiterais rajouter des
tables et table à tel endroit et on va
des bons films
nos terrasses après un week-end de trois
jours dont un jour férié le lundi
donc ça a été extrêmement compliqué de
réagir rapidement pour accueillir nos
clients et élargir nos terrasses et
espérer faire un petit peu d'activité
donc oui demi mesure on va revenir
évidemment sur ces restrictions je me
tourne vers jean pierre pin et les
vice-présidents donc de faire des
grandes maisons corses
vous êtes soulagés jean pierre pinelli
pour vous la situation est plutôt
favorable encore des zones vertes la
saison et ce qui va les sauver
ça y est ou c'est peut être trop tôt de
gafsa non c'est trop tôt la saison n'est
pas sauvée mais d'abord je voudrais
avoir une pensée pour ceux qui vont
affronter la maladie et est le co vie
parce que c'est vrai que de l'aspect
sanitaire ne doit pas on doit pas
l'oublier
d'une part 2e à l'insatisfaction et c
est que justement cette situation
s'améliore et qu'on va déjà pouvoir
emboîté le pas sur le discours
économique et nous sommes satisfaits
parce que ce qui nous importe c'est
évident nous les professionnels c'est
d'abord c'est cette notion descendre
kilomètres qu'il me paraissait un petit
peu peut être un peu forte du moins car
on est c'est une économie des mobilités
vous savez aujourd'hui de surtout le
tourisme
donc ça nous paraissait même un peu
juste de ne pas pouvoir se déplacer des
100 km alors vous vous êtes plutôt
sauver entend ce parce que les terrasses
ça y est quasiment que ça les hôtels
vont rouvrir vous quelle est votre
situation des propriétaires d'hôtels
également vous allait rouvrir rapidement
les choses vont se passer de quelle
manière très difficile pour nous dans
l'immédiat dans la mesure où non à une
contrainte c'est celle d'orly tant que
les rebords d'orly n'ouvrira pas y
compris ce 26 juin sauf erreur de ma
part c'était l'une des annonces
effectivement de la journée de la part
des doigts philippins oui mais voilà 26
juin effectivement annonce afp
l'aéroport d'orly il va donc ouvrir le
26 juin tout à fait donc sur la france
continentale est difficile il n'est pas
difficile de se déplacer on a plusieurs
moyens de locomotion pour nous c'est
essentiellement la hérie
qui dit un petit peu le devenir de la
saison donc on attend avec impatience
l'ouverture d'orly d'une part et
d'ensuite vous savez que nous sommes
encore en discussion sur ce fameux green
parce que le président de l'exécutif a
eu cette idée je ne sais d'où le doubs
il l'a prise mais du moins là évoqué et
pour le moment on n'a pas eu on
attendait une réponse du premier
ministre ce soir à ce sujet qu'elle est
qu'elle est là les conditions et comment
le gouvernement veut gérer cette ce
green basse on attend on verra dans les
jours à venir du moins le mois de juin
malgré l'autorisation du 2 juin est pour
nous très impacté pascal mons et vous
comprenez justement le président de
région qui il va effectivement se
protéger ce green pass on veut relancer
l'économie bien évidemment on veut
retourner au travail mais voilà avec
beaucoup de sécurité et des garanties
je pense que ça dépasse le cadre de la
corse la distanciation physique que nous
impose cette maladie est contraire à
l'adn de nos métiers et l'adn de nos
métiers c'est de rapprocher les gens
s'est créé la convivialité de rapprocher
les gens plutôt que les éloigner donc
nos entreprises elles resteront
durablement impacté tant que la
distanciation physique sera de mise et
iliad les médecins et les spécialistes
qui pourront nous dispenser de cette
cette contrainte
donc on est les secteurs du café de
l'hôtel restaurant discothèque tous ces
établissements sont vraiment
économiquement très très fragilisée
pendant toute la période des mois qui
vont qui vont arriver malgré l'ouverture
aujourd'hui économiquement on est tous
contraints à travailler à perte pendant
une durée
indéterminée et ce caractère
indéterminée il la maîtrise du temps
qu'on a pas va précipiter beaucoup
d'entreprises qui n'ont pas de
ressources sur le long terme dans des
difficultés et mélasse dans la
disparition
aujourd'hui notre combat il est de
minimiser l'impact sur les entreprises
en étant accompagné on a quand même un
sujet des loyers que moi je je trouve
important parce qu'aujourd'hui les
dispositions législatives ne permettent
pas de faire plier les bailleurs et les
bailleurs aujourd'hui peuvent très bien
depuis le 15 mars exige l intégralité
des loyers est dire le vide ne nous
concerne pas et du côté des entreprises
que l'on défend les cafés les hôtels
restaurants on a derrière des impacts
sociaux et de l'emploi et nous on
demanderait aux bailleurs et on demande
aux bailleurs et à tous les
propriétaires d'hôtels café-restaurant
de tenir compte de ce phénomène toko
vide et d'adapter pendant deux ou trois
trimestres leur demande de loyer voire
de les annuler sur la période de
fermeture ce qui est une demande
récurrente qu'on a depuis plusieurs mois
et le président macron nous a
accompagnés dans cette demande le 24
avril il a invité les collectivités
locales à annuler les loyers pour les
entreprises de notre secteur d'activité
donnez moi mais vous vous dites on va
être condamné à travailler à perte
pendant quelques mois
on va y revenir parce que c'est vrai
qu'on prend beaucoup de temps pour les
réponses sur ces deux mesures quand même
restrictive mais ça veut dire qu'il y
aura des établissements qui vont être
tentées finalement de ne pas rouvrir ça
peut ne pas être si rentable pour eux
d'ouvrir par exemple jean pierre pinelli
vous avez été sur vos de vouloir ouvrir
vos hôtels tout de suite au final on
peut se poser la question et mettre les
choses en balance il est évident que
cette saison on aura pas d'entente
habilité si des gens ne perd pas
d'argent
c'était c'est un exploit on peut pas si
vous voulez après ce choc qui est
inhumain mettre en route nos entreprises
et se dire qu'on va retrouver d'abord
quel présentation on va t'on avoir comme
le disait monsieur les mesures barrières
sont est assez contraignante et en même
temps
avoir un choc émotionnel qui va se pour
le moment on est un peu aseptisé par ce
choc mais le évidemment il y aura un
choc émotionnel et psychologique qui va
suivre alors 10 par table maximum un
joli voici les mesures de réflexion à
mettre entre chaque table parce qu'elle
on sait comment vous voyez les choses on
imagine que c'est beaucoup plus simple
selon les établissements
je tenais pas tous logés à une enseigne
le petit bistrot qui avait eu sa place
aujourd'hui est en danger si en plus il
a pas de terrasse je vois pas comment il
peut s'en sortir
les établissements qui ont plus de place
qui disposent de terrasses pourront plus
facilement s'adapter et recevoir et
avoir un petit peu de chiffre d'affaires
pour remettre leurs collaborateurs au
travail
la différence qui nous sépare entre
calvi et paris c'est que calvi attaque
la haute saison et la corse la pac à
tout le littoral attaque la haute saison
donc l'opportunité pour ces
établissements d'avoir un petit peu
cheap d'affaires est plus importante
du fait de l'appétence des français de
ceux qui pourront se déplacer a quand
même profité des vacances sortir de ce
contexte anxiogène qui nous accompagne
depuis le 15 mars
nous à paris on est dans la situation
inverse on attaque la basse saison à
partir de la mi juin les grandes
métropoles se vide notamment paris cette
année 15 millions touristes étrangers ne
viendront pas et grands musées sont
fermés il y à l'attractivité de paris
s'en trouve fortement diminué et donc
nous attaquons la basse saison donc
l'opportunité que nos entreprises et 1
ne serait ce qu'un équilibre est
complètement hors de propos
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des activités de
restauration et d'hôtellerie vont perdre
de l'argent à paris pendant les trois à
quatre mois qui viennent cette
incontournable il n'y a plus de marché
si vous voulez il ya il n'y a pas de
demande et il ya une offre pléthorique
donc
on voit pas comment économiquement
équilibrer nos exploitations à part les
petites structures qui ont très peu de
frais de personnel qui ont très peu de
collaborateurs
quand des petits loyers pourront
peut-être tiré leur épingle du jeu
mais les structures un peu importante on
connaît les loyers parisiens vont se
retrouver très vite en difficulté à
l'automne dernière question jean pierre
pinelli la tentation peut-être pour
certains d'augmenter les prix cet été
justement pour compenser un petit peu
surtout pas vous savez avec la reprise
c'est la reprise dès que les frontières
seront ouvertes ce sera la reprise des
autres pays aussi puisqu'elle vous le
savez ça échappe à personne ça a impacté
la planète et les autres pays feront
aussi des prix et vous le savez on est
difficilement concurrentiel sur l'offre
déjà qui est qualitative un peu partout
en europe et au-delà apprenez le maghreb
on va pas te le magal et en même temps
ces gens-là rebonds ont eux aussi baissé
les prix donc il est difficile mais ils
n'ont pas les mêmes codes sociaux et les
causes mêmes codes fiscaux c'est pour ça
que je vous aurais ce monsieur sait que
le gouvernement et l'état devront faire
des efforts colossaux pour monétiser
pour injecter des liquidités sans quoi
il faudra recréer le cercle vertueux si
vous voulez delà de la production de la
consommation et la fiscalité c'est
impératif où mes peintures grand merci à
vous en tout cas je conclus sur un
sondage plutôt optimiste pour vous 84%
des français se disent prêts tout à fait
prêt à retourner dans les bars cafés
restaurants lors de leur réouverture
selon un sondage opinion way en tout cas
bonne chance à vous merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france quatre jours donc
avant de regoûter à certaines libertés
le bilan du coronavirus dans l'hexagone
continue de baisser selon les chiffres
de la direction générale de la santé oms
compte 66 nouveaux décès à l'hôpital en
24 heures au total à 28 mille six cent
soixante deux personnes sont mortes
depuis le début de l'épidémie
les résultats sont bons a précisé
edouard philippe lors de son allocution
tout en rappelant évidemment
l'importance des gestes barrières où le
port du masque
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur le discours
d'edouard philippe place à la phase 2
donc dû
et confinement le 2 juin la france qui
passe au vert sauf en ile-de-france en
guyane et à mayotte qui passe à l'orangé
puis ce sera les ditto et qu'on le plan
de relance de la commission européenne
est il à la hauteur de la récession
historique qui nous attend jacques sapir
tentera de répondre à cette question
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'hérault pour les
états unis quelle stratégie vous avez
déployés dans le sud kivu pour limiter
la propagation du virus on a proposé à
ce qu'est le confinement puisse être
sélectif est concerné seulement des
personnes âgées à haut risque de
complication pour sensibiliser la
population ça l'est beaucoup plus
facilement puisque on venait de sortir
d'une épidémie à ebola qui exige
également la distanciation social lavage
des mains tutorat
si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très
difficile pour nous
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des féminicides
aujourd'hui en france l'écho et les
violences existait avant leur
confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre les quatre les
taux de féminicide a plus que je t'ai
pas doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
bourreau n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en eût clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violence de nos grandes pas à 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france le
premier ministre edouard philippe les
ministres de l'éducation et de la santé
ont donc présenté la phase 2 du
déconfinement olivier ferrand a fait le
point notamment sur les régions encore
en vigilance orange dont fait partie l
ile-de-france a coûté en ile de france
cette vigilance est justifiée en raison
de la persistance à la fois d'un taux
d'incidence encore élevé sur certains
départements de la région et d'un taux
de patients hospitalisés en réanimation
encore élevé pour l'île de france nous
avons considéré que les mesures doivent
être prises à l'échelle de la région et
non pas du département compte tenu d'une
part de la forte densité de la
population dans cette région mais
également des réseaux de transport et de
la grande mobilité des habitants à
travers les départements de la région et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec catherine hill épidémiologiste
bonsoir catherine hill merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors les
résultats sont bons sur le plan
sanitaire nous expliquer le premier
ministre ajoutant évidemment qu'on ne
pouvait pas courir le risque de la
désinvolture que le virus était encore
présent sur le territoire
il n'empêche à partir de deux joints la
liberté va devenir la règle et
l'interdiction deviendra l'exception
votre réaction à ce diagnostic catherine
hill bien à la fois tout le monde est
content si c'est en avance tout va mieux
mais quand même le virus continue à
circuler
et ça c'est quand même une souci donc
plus de gens vont rencontrer plus de
gens dont qu'ils augmentent leurs
chances d'être infectés c'est ça le
problème
il va falloir surveiller de très près
est ce que je déplore c'est qu'on a
n'est pas toujours pas une stratégie de
tests très très large
en fait il faudrait tester beaucoup plus
largement que ce qui est prévu de faire
on ne teste que les gens qui sont
symptomatiques et leurs contacts
mais il ya beaucoup de contamination qui
sont qui viennent de gens qui sont
asymptomatiques c'est cela qu'il faut
trouver le virus continue à circuler
c'est bien ça le problème
à partir du moment catherine hill où on
n'a pas les tests que vous appelez de
vos voeux
vous trouvez que cette accélération dans
le déconfinement annoncée par le premier
ministre va peut-être un peu trop vite
ou c'était la bonne décision à prendre
aujourd'hui selon vous moi je pense que
vous faire faire autrement
sinon on va vers une catastrophe
économique qui est encore bien plus
embêtant donc voilà il faut faut bien
avancer
donc on ne peut pas faire autrement mais
il faut que tout le monde continue à
faire très très attention
les gens continuent à se promener dans
paris je parle j'ai marché aujourd'hui
il ya la moitié qui n'a pas de masque
donc ça c'est vraiment un problème
si vous êtes un peu longtemps avec des
gens qui se savent pas contaminés et
qu'il crache du virus au tour ne vous
êtes un risque de tomber malade c'est
quand même embêtant
donc il faut que tout le monde porte un
masque pour que ceux qui sont positifs
et qu'ils ne savent pas porte un masque
c'est sale c'est ça la règle est
pourtant sauf erreur de ma part pas
vraiment de mots alors évidemment sur
les gestes barrières en général mais
toujours pas d'obligation de porter de
masque un exigé par le premier ministre
c'est peut-être que ce qu'il aurait pu
faire selon vous non obligation non mais
être clair en disant quand vous êtes
dehors comme vous êtes dans une boutique
maintenant tout le monde a compris qu'il
valait porter un masque mais dehors
aussi parce que vous allez croiser des
gens et puis vous allez monter dans
l'autobus vous avez oublié de mettre
votre masque il faut la voir tout le
temps c'est sale c'est ça le truc c'est
pas une option
il faut que ça soit vraiment intégré
dans la rue là dans les images on vous
montrait on voit déjà invité parce que
c'est bien mais il y en a beaucoup qui
n'ont pas non plus pignon sur sous le
manteau ou autour du cou dans leur poche
je vous avez interviewé il ya quelques
jours avec effectivement les images de
ce canal saint-martin rempli de monde ça
vous faisait voilà un petit peu frémir
aujourd'hui les parcs et jardins vont
rouvrir notamment dans la capitale qui
est toujours en zone orange à la demande
d'ailleurs de la maire de paris la règle
des 100 km et bien c'est fini également
le plus grand danger il vient de là au
contraire des rassemblements qu'évoquer
edouard philippe le danger vient de
partout selon vous aujourd'hui
il ya deux choses qui font le danger la
première chose c'est combien de gens se
promènent en ile de france
aujourd'hui en étant positif et on ne
sachant pas en étant contaminants et on
ne sachant pas on sait pas si c'est un
sur mille ou un sur dix mille c'est
quand même embêtant
et la deuxième chose il faut si on
connaissait ça on peut réfléchir à
combien de gens différents on a croisé
dans la journée donc puis vous croisez
le jean et plus il ya de gens
contaminants plus vous avez de chance à
tomber malade
c'est très simple à une arithmétique
très très simple en fait
alors 4000 le virus circule toujours ça
tout le monde est d'accord pour le dire
il n'empêche l'épidémie semble marquer
le pas les médecins ne sont pas toujours
d'accord
l'un des premiers c'est didier raoul qui
disait à prédire que l'épidémie
partirait avec les beaux jours que
c'était saisonniers j'espère que je
relate bien ces propos mais que le virus
continue à circuler
est-ce que vous pouvez envisager
aujourd'hui finalement qu'il n'y aura
pas de deuxième vague et que ce virus
est en train par bonheur peut-être de
disparaître justement avec la belle
saison est ce que vous l'envisagez vous
j'aimerais bien pouvoir l'envisager mais
je surveille les indicateurs et des
indicateurs les tout à diminuer les
hospitalisations les admission en
réanimation et nombre de mois ça a
baissé régulièrement s'abaisser d'abord
vite au moment au début du confinement
qui ensuite plus lentement et maintenant
encore plus lentement tellement que son
est arrivé quelque chose d'un peu
constant et donc c'est difficile de dire
si ça va recommencer à augmenter ou
rester au niveau c'est ou bien diminué
c'est vraiment impossible de prévoir
mais ce que je déplore c'est qu'on ne
fasse pas des tests massivement comme
avouera par exemple où il ya le virus va
continuer ou a réapparu
ils ont décidé qu'ils allaient tester
toute la population et ils vont tester
toute la population en faisant des tests
groupe et c'est à dire
mettant les prélèvements de 20 personnes
dans le même tube pour regarder s'il ya
du virus dans l'ensemble de ses vins
prélèvements si c'est négatif ces 20
personnes sont présumées négative
donc on peut tester beaucoup plus de
gens avec ce système mais ici on parle
pas du tout de tester des gens qui ne
sont pas symptomatique sauf des contacts
de personnes sont automatiques et ça
c'est un problème
merci en tout cas catherine hill
épidémiologiste avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france le personnel
soignant ont félicité d'ailleurs par
edouard philippe cet après midi lui
maintient à la pression avec un nouveau
rassemblement aujourd'hui devant
l'hôpital robert debré à paris un
rassemblement également organisés pour
exprimer une nouvelle fois les
revendications des blouses blanches
manifestation aussi à bordeaux où une
centaine d'infirmières médecins et
soignants ou encore personnels
administratifs se sont donné rendez vous
au chu
cette manifestation intervient alors que
le ségur de la santé a entamé son
quatrième jour de concertation on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
manifestations avant qu'il y ait le coc
vide
personne n'a voulu rien entendre et
heureusement sur le sumo ajs on a eu de
la chance puisqu'on n'a pas eu une
grosse vague mais on était prêt si on
est à l'heure actuelle toujours frais
si on avait pris en compte ce que lors
des manifestations selon avaient tous
dit on aurait pas eu tous ces soucis
tous ces problèmes qu'à masquer tous ces
personnels qui ont été impactés par le
corps puisque j'attends de la
concertation de ségur
c'est que les jeunes aient suffisamment
envie de venir pour qu'on puisse avoir
suffisamment de bras pour travailler et
que ben en fait on est plein de gens qui
rêvent de faire notre travail et non
plus en tant des gens qui disent ah non
c'est dur à l'hôpital parce qu'à chaque
reportage où on nous dit voilà il ya des
conditions difficiles on a des jeunes
qui s'en vont on ne lâchera pas parce
que bon ben il ya un gros manque de
personnel un gros manque de moyens de
tous nos infirmières belle leçon épuisé
tout le monde est épuisé et je pense que
ben il faut qu'on se batte pour pour
tout ça on espère on espère que ça
changera quelque chose qu'on se mobilise
pour quelque chose n'est pas pour rien
qu'ils vont nous écouter la disparition
d'une figure de la droite le député l
air à claude goasguen est décédé ce fmi
annoncé sa mort ce matin l'âge de 75 ans
il se remettait tout juste du
coronavirus en raison duquel il venait
passer 22 jours en réanimation
l ancien maire du xvième arrondissement
de paris je cite aller mieux et
remarcher il a ensuite connu des
complications cardiaques
claude goasguen vient de partir emporter
par cette saloperie qu'importe ce que la
politique peut en dire
il était mon ami et j'ai été le sien
depuis nos 20 ans et tous les deux nous
le savions
c'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que
j'apprends le décès de claude goasguen
kim avait parrainé à deux reprises aux
élections internes
c'était un homme courageux fort en
gueule et diablement sympathique
adieu claude tu nous manques pensées
attristées aux proches famille amis et
compagnons de route de claude goasguen
qui nous quitte aujourd'hui victime du
coc vite 19
adieu à notre collègue claude goasguen
il y avait du cirano chez se fier
bretteur de l'assemblée nationale qui
s'ennuyait lorsque les eaux étaient
calmes et n'aimait rien tant que le
fracas des batailles et relance à 750
milliards d'euros pour l'union
européenne
la commission de bruxelles a présenté
son plan pour répondre avec les u
coronavirus il fait la part belle aux
subventions et favorise les pays les
plus touchés comme l'italie et l'espagne
ce plan qui s'inspire en grande partie
des propositions françaises et
allemandes peut-il remporter l'adhésion
des plus réfractaires comme les pays-bas
ou l'autriche est il à la hauteur de la
récession historique qui nous attend on
voit cela avec vous jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques alors jacquet bonsoir
c'est fait les beaux soirs cette réponse
de la part de lieux qui a tardé temps et
elle au niveau des espérances et surtout
des besoins jacques
non absolument pas vous savez ici on
compare avec ce que font par exemple les
autres grands pays que ce soit la chine
où que ce soit les états unis et bien
les sommes qui sont tant que sont très
faibles pour l'union européenne on est
actuellement autour de 3 % du pib alors
qu'on est entre 7 et 10% pour le plan de
relance seulement je parle pas des des
plans d'accompagnement de la crise née
pour le plan de relance seulement on est
entre 7 et 10% du pib en chine et aux
états unis
alors oui on voit bien il ya un gros
problème maintenant le plan franco
allemand qui a été présentée le lundi 18
mai eh bien il propose 540 milliards ce
qui n'est pas rien évidemment puisque ça
viendrait s'ajouter aux 500 milliards
qui était déjà prévu mais ses 540
milliards eh bien il va s'agir
essentiellement de transferts
budgétaires puisque c'est de l'argent
que la commission de bruxelles
les vrais directement sur les marchés le
problème c'est évidemment cette
proposition a provoqué une crispation
chez les pays du nord ce qu'on appelle
les quatre frugaux la hollande la suède
le danemark vraiment et l'autriche et
que évidemment et bien on est parti dans
une dans un cycle de négociations on
peut même parler qu'on est parti pour un
nouveau cycle des faux semblant alors
jacques commençons par à la proposition
franco allemand en fait avant ce plan de
relance de quoi s'agissait-il
alors faut savoir que cette proposition
c'était déjà un compromis la france elle
vous les implants à 1500 milliards
l'allemagne a dit non mais elle a
accepté et ça c'est un point
effectivement très important elle a
accepté une forme de mutualisation des
dettes ce qu'elle avait complètement
refusé auparavant
alors ce plan de 500 milliards c'est de
l'argent qui viendra d'un endettement de
la commission européenne cet argent sera
redistribué aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin
il sera redistribuée sous la forme de
subventions budgétaires ce qui équivaut
en faire quasiment des dons et puis bien
entendu au niveau du remboursement et
bien si jamais ces sommes sont
remboursés parce qu'il n'est pas du tout
sûr qu'elles soient remboursées bien si
jamais ces sommes doivent être un jour
rembourser elles le seront
essentiellement par des contributions au
budget ce qui veut dire que ce nouvel
endettement ne viendra pas s'inscrire
dans l'endettement déjà pris par ces
différents pays ça ne viendra pas sur le
fameux ratio dette / pimkie si important
pour certains pays on pense notamment à
l'italie
pourtant cette proposition jacques n'a
pas fait plaisir à tout le monde qu'on
que non stéphanie haut que non et si
vous voulez donc les les quatre pays que
j'ai citées ce qu'on appelle les quatre
frugaux ont immédiatement réagi au delà
il faut voir qu'il ya peut-être une
maladresse dans la manière dont ce plan
a été présenté parce que à faire un plan
entre la france et l'allemagne à ne pas
s'associer et d'autres pays qui sont des
pays importants l'italie 3e
maintenant c'est là c'est la troisième
économie de l'union européenne l'espagne
voire la belgique
ou le portugal à ne pas associer ces
pays et on a donné l'impression que ben
voilà il y avait des pays qui étaient
plus égaux que d'autres pour reprendre
la phrase d'orwell et que la france et
l'allemagne voulait gouverner
l'union européenne alors au delà de
cette maladresse bien il est clair qu'il
ya une opposition des pays dits frugaux
qui vraiment rejette la dynamique
globale de ce plan alors ces pays dits
frugaux 1 comme vous dites que
propose-t-il alors ces billets c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre
d'un côté ils sont tout à fait d'accord
sur l'idée d'un fonds de relance et qui
serait là lié aux circonstances tout à
fait exceptionnelles que nous vivons
c'est pas là dessus que se posent
l'essentiel du problème eux ce qu'ils
proposent c'est que on est un plan qui
soit en fait fondés sur des prêts
ponctuelle aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin
d'ailleurs c'est un point important il
ne mentionne aucune somme donc ça c'est
déjà un point qu'il faut relever et
c'est si vous laissez près ponctuelles
et bien il servirait évidemment à faire
des investissements dans les secteurs
qui en ont le plus besoin
évidemment l'économie verte la recherche
l'innovation mais il serait soumis à
l'engagement ferme pris par les pays qui
contracteraient évidemment un cdh est
donc cet engagement ferme à mettre en
oeuvre des réformes et à rester de
manière absolument strict dans les clous
de l'orthodoxie budgétaire et en quoi
jackass différent de la proposition
franco allemande alors alors une
première différence évidente un hymne et
plus du tout question de dette
mutualisée et là on voit très bien c'est
une rupture avec ce que veulent ou ce
que voudrait paris et berlin
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est
que si vous voulez ce plan et bien il
fait référence aux grands principes
fondamentaux de l'union européenne et
ses principes fondamentaux ce sont
exactement les mêmes que ceux qui sous
tendent le fameux
mécanisme si vous le mécanisme européen
de stabilité le ms
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire pour les pays qui contracteraient
des dettes dans ce cadre eh bien ça veut
dire se mettre sous la coupe de la
troïka se mettre dans la même situation
qu on était le portugal la grèce voire
l'espagne
de plus et c'est un point important les
quatre frugaux ne veulent pas que ce
plan de relance soit d'une certaine
manière pour l'éternité
ils demandent que la période soit
réduite à deux ans et ils demandent
surtout qu'il y ait une évaluation du
risque financier que ceux ci ferait
prendre à la commission alors est on
pour les desiderata non malheureusement
non ces pays ont même d'autres exigences
alors ils ont des exigences très nette
en ce qui concerne le budget européen
vous savez qu'on va devoir rediscuter du
budget européen sur la période 2021 et
2027 d'ailleurs à cause de la crise que
nous vivons actuellement est là encore
il demande à ce que ce soit des règles
d'austérité et des règles de frugalité
qui prévalent
il considère qu'il est dangereux que les
pays de l'union européenne
je dirais s'habitue à des budgets trop
important et pour en revenir jacquot
plan de rela the relance de la
commission comment ont-elles le financer
alors c'est un point intéressant la
commission européenne a fait mercredi à
dernier a fait des propositions qui
d'ailleurs s'inspire assez largement des
propositions qui avaient été faites par
la france et l'allemagne
là encore il s'agirait d'un emprunt que
prendrait directement la commission
alors le point qui est un petit peu
important le point qui tranche
peut-être dans cette promenade dans
cette proposition de la commission par
rapport à la proposition franco
allemande
c'est que d'avoir les plus importantes
grosso modo 750 milliards mais elle est
divisée en deux il ya d'une part 500
milliards qui seraient en réalité des
fonds budgétaires et là on retrouve la
mécanique qui était celle du plan franco
allemand et puis il ya 250 milliards qui
seraient plutôt des prêts accordés
aux différents pays alors le point sur
lequel il faut peut-être bien revenir
c'est le fait que la commission exige en
réalité que les priorités politiques
qu'elle a fixés en particulier la
transition écologique que ce qu'on
appelle le fameux green deal que ses
priorités politiques soient respectés et
d'autre part il est clair qu'elle veut
avancer sur cette idée de mutualisation
des dettes alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire là ça veut dire que il n'ya pas là
de deux points de compromis entre ce que
propose des quatre frugaux est ce que
propose la commission que donc les
débats vont être houleux et qu'il faudra
de nombreuses réunions du conseil
européen pour pouvoir avancer sur cette
question si tenté que l'on avance aimé
jacquet voyez-vous tout de même avec
tout ce que vous nous dites un compromis
avec ces quatre pays et 4 go bah si vous
voulez je pense qu'un compromis est
d'une certaine manière inévitable mais
il est très clair que on est en présence
d'une opposition forte de la part de ces
cas pays et il faut rappeler que s'il
n'ya pas l'unanimité
ça ne peut pas s'ils voulaient ces
propositions ne peuvent pas se
concrétiser dans un port
qu'est ce que pourraient être les bases
un compromis très certainement de
renforcer le contrôle de la commission
sur le budget des pays qui prendrait de
l'argent qu'ils obtiendraient de
l'argent à travers les différents
mécanismes peut-être une réduction de
l'endettement général de la commission
bref on irait plutôt dans je dirais le
domaine d'un plus grand contrôle sur les
sommes qui seraient à ce moment là à
utiliser et ça c'est un point que
l'espagne et surtout l'italie semble
vouloir refuser absolument
donc voilà on est parti pour un débat et
une négociation qui sera extrêmement
difficile pour résumé jacques si on vous
lit bien vous n'êtes pas optimiste et
hélas non et je dois dire que je
voudrais est trop petit mais si vous
regardez grosso modo les sommes qui sont
en cause avec le plan franco allemand on
est grosso modo autour de 1000 milliards
d'euros avec le plan de la commission
12150 si on regarde le plan de relance
qui a été déjà acté
aux etats unis ses 2300 milliards
or l'économie américaine elle est en
fait plus petit que l'économie de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne donc déjà là il ya un
problème tout à fait évident et je passe
évidemment sur la question des
négociations qui seront comme je voulais
dit extrêmement difficile en fait la
solution qui aurait été la plus
rationnelle et certainement la plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre
c'était la solution qui consistait à
dire aux pays-bas écoutez vous faites
les plans dont vous avez besoin
on va pas regarder ce que vous faites
est votre endettement et bien c'est
directement la banque centrale
européenne qui le reprend oui mais
malheureusement il y à l'arrêt du 5 mai
de la cour de cadeaux seront qui est
venu d'une certaine manière faire
capoter
je dirais tout cette belle mécanique et
c'est peut-être pour ça que l'on est
aujourd'hui rentré dans cette logique de
propositions qui devront être âprement
discutés dans plusieurs conseils
européens
vraiment merci jacques pour toutes ces
explications qui nous donne à réfléchir
mercier vous et à bientôt et à bientôt
sur rt france restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la phase ii du déconfinement partir du 2
juin et la fin de la limitation des 100
km sur le plan sanitaire les résultats
sont bons a précisé edouard philippe
télétravailler par dumas sont toujours
recommandé les masques justement en la
justice enquête sur l'ex collaborateur
d'olivier verront soupçonnées de trafic
d'influencé
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais c'est une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que tous les pays
de la planète décide finalement de
sacrifier leurs économies pour sauver
des vies humaines
bien sûr c'est sauver des vies mais
c'est aussi conservé l'appareil
productif et permettent que ceux qui
sont dans les secteurs essentiels ceux
qui sont essentiels à l'économie du pays
puissent continuer aussi à travailler
dans le même temps
diriez vous que l'économie française est
dans une situation catastrophique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que toutes les
planètes sont pas encore alignée pour
qu'on puisse absolument se dire qu'on va
réussir à surmonter de la meilleure
manière possible cette crise j'imagine
que l'initiative franco allemande
s'inscrit dans bug dans votre logique
les 500 milliards c'est une enveloppe et
il ya un peu une enveloppe en termes de
communication pour l'instant un
engagement oui mais ça veut pas dire que
rabat contrepartie croire que cette
critique au vide aurait effacé les
handicaps que nous portions france fait
croire que va pouvoir repartir à zéro
sans régler les problèmes d'hier et
c'est une erreur
[Musique]
ton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le lise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez non pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'après eux mêmes et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
on est allé faire ailleurs ce qu'on
pouvait faire chez nous mais qui coûtait
trop cher à faire chez nous avons
aujourd'hui des usines qui ferment en
france pour se mettre dans les pays de
l'est en pologne en roumanie ailleurs
selon vous ce noël est trop loin dans la
mondialisation
le principal problème c'est c'est aussi
l'europe et l'euro on est allé trop loin
surtout dans la désindustrialisation de
pays en france on trouve pas mal de
choses sauf que ça ne passe jamais dans
l'industrie ça pourrait créer des
emplois ça pourrait créer de la
croissance mais nous on recherche pour
la beauté de la recherche avant tout le
problème pour moi c'est la méfiance
globale de notre pays a les gaz
industriels
il faut soutenir les industriels c'est
pas les intellectuels de bercy et de
dire comment l'industrie succès les
industriels qui me parle de ça moi et
qu'ils le feront
[Musique]
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus au nord proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront rassembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on peut pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment caissettes
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 28 mai disparition de la
limitation des 100 km réouverture des
restaurants et des bars à partir du 2
juin partout en zone verte en terrains
seulement en zone orange réouverture est
progressif des collèges et lycées en
zone orange également et annulation du
bas chorale français c'est en substance
ce qu'il faut retenir de la phase 2 du
déconfinement présenté ce soir par
edouard philippe qui salue une situation
fruit du bon travail de tous les
soignants un signe de la rigueur de tous
les français
la troisième phase ce sera pour le 22
juin le torchon brûle entre donald trump
et twitter le président américain
multiplie les menaces à l'encontre du
réseau social qui a pris la décision
d'ajouter une mise en garde ces messages
véhiculant des informations non
vérifiées après avoir mené ces de
réglementer et fermé twitter le
locataire de la maison blanche va signer
aujourd'hui un décret dont le contenu
demeure encore inconnue c'est finalement
samedi que le premier vol habité de
space x d'ecône rats les deux américains
obtenus de super-héros prendront place à
bord de la capsule dragon a lancé par
une fusée falcon 9
avec ce vol à la firme d'elon musk
deviendra la première entreprise privée
envoyer des astronautes dans l'espace
même s'il s'effectuera sous la tutelle
de la nasa
[Musique]
plus d'une heure d'allocutions donc pour
le premier ministre entouré les mini de
l'éducation et de la santé pour
présenter la phase 2 du déconfinement
voici ce qu'il faut en retenir avec
grégoire dos et la liberté enfin va
redevenir la règle et l'interdiction
constituera l'exception une bascule qui
sonne comme une bouffée d'oxygène pour
les français le pays repose quasi
exclusivement en verre seule exception
les départements d'ile-de-france mayotte
et la guyane qui constitueront la zone
orange le déconfinement il sera un peu
plus prudents a prévenu le premier
ministre
parmi les interdictions levée il sera de
nouveau possible d'aller dans les parcs
et jardins en zone orange tous les cafés
bars et restaurants vont rouvrir en zone
verte ainsi que les terrasses dans les
départements classées en orange
la limitation de déplacement à 100 km du
domicile ne sera quant à elle plus
d'actualité à partir du 2 juin
edouard philippe a toutefois tenu à
rappeler la nécessité de maintenir la
vigilance
mais cette liberté retrouvée implique
des contraintes qui sont en quelque
sorte des contreparties la limitation
des regroupements à 10 personnes dans
l'espace public est maintenu le principe
du recours au télétravail doit toujours
être privilégiés on le comprend bien le
respect des gestes barrières surtout
doit rester très rigoureux et le port du
masque est maintenant largement
recommandée par les autorités sanitaires
nous continuerons et j'en suis désolé
mais c'est mon devoir a limité les
formes de la vie sociale les plus
propices à la transmission du virus les
sports de contact les boîtes de nuit les
regroupements de très large public en
particulier le ministre le dira il faut
éviter les rassemblements de personnes
dans les lieux couverts et sans
organisation adaptée
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer a pour sa part fait le point
sur les réouvertures des collèges et des
lycées
l'ensemble des collèges vont désormais
ouvrir que ce soit en zone verte ou en
zone orange en zone verte cela signifie
donc que l'on n'ajoute la 4e et la
troisième après la 6e et la cinquième
qui ont déjà ouvert
donc l'ensemble des classes sont
ouvertes en zone verte en zone orange
nous allons accueillir en priorité les
élèves de 6e et de 5e et si les
conditions matérielles sont réunies les
élèves des autres niveaux pourront
ensuite être accueilli l'ensemble des
lycées vont ouvrir avec un protocole
sanitaire qui est le même que pour celui
des collèges en zone verte
cela signifie que les lycées généraux
technologiques et professionnels vont
rouvrir et accueillir progressivement
les élèves dans le secteur de la culture
musées et monuments rouvriront à partir
de mardi prochain avec port du masque
obligatoire en zone verte ce sera
également le cas pour les théâtres et
salles de spectacles tous les cinémas
suivront le 22 juin l'interdiction de la
pratique des sports collectifs et des
sports de contact est en revanche
maintenue jusqu'à nouvel ordre
enfin le premier ministre a apporté des
précisions sur la saison estivale des
hébergements touristiques les villages
vacances les campings pourront ouvrir à
partir du 2 juin dans tous les
départements à l'exception de ceux qui
font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière dans ces départements la
les hébergements en question les
campings les auberges collectif ne
pourrons rouvrir que dans la troisième
phase de déconfinement c'est à dire
après le 22 juin les déplacements y
compris en europe seront je l'espère
autorisée concernant les relations hors
europe
il nous faudra nous harmonisé avec nos
pays voisins et prendre des décisions en
fonction de l'état et de l'évolution des
risques je les dis les enfants pourront
être inscrits en colonie de vacances ou
en camps de plein air des perspectives
plutôt réjouissante
après plus de deux mois éprouvants pour
les français et pour parler de cette
nouvelle phase nous sommes en direct
avec bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir duster2 grand merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les résultats sont donc bon sur le plan
sanitaire sanitaire nous dit edouard
philippe
à partir du 2 juin la liberté va devenir
à la règle et l'interdiction deviendra
l'exception le médecin que vous êtes
comment ils jeu cette nouvelle stratégie
du gouvernement
non mais probablement
on voit bien dans leur cabinet depuis
maintenant une petite semaine que les
tests que l'on réalise reviennent plutôt
négatif que la contamination entre les
personnes et de moins en moins
importante et on se rend bien compte que
la virulence du virus a nettement
diminué alors malheureusement je pense
que beaucoup de politiques vont vouloir
crier victoire mais je ne suis pas
certain que ce soit lié réellement à une
stratégie politique mais simplement
l'effet naturel d'une fin de défilé
alors ça veut dire concrètement dr
legrand que didier rahout dont on a
beaucoup parlé cette semaine avait
finalement un petit peu raison quand
même sur ce coup là il avait dit
effectivement cette épidémie selon lui
s'évaporer avec la saison estivale elle
deviendrait comme elle est apparue
est ce que vous le rejoignez dans cette
analyse aujourd'hui sur ce point oui il
avait d'ailleurs lui ai dit et ça et il
a dit exactement l'inversé aussi vécu
des choses donc en bon fils urologue
il n'y a pas de problème il a fui bon
après faut entrer plaisanterie
effectivement une vilenie ça se termine
généralement nationalement heureusement
il faut quand même se rappeler que
à chaque fois l'état a beaucoup de
retard pour se mettre en place pour
diminuer la contamination et on va avoir
la chance d'avoir un milliard de masques
qui devrait arriver fin du mois de juin
donc s'ils ont des stocks qui compte
vraiment pas normalement que la
prochaine étape
alors docteur de grands vous vous dites
c'est pas vraiment dû à la stratégie du
gouvernement
ça veut dire que le confinement n'y est
pour rien où il aurait quand même
évidemment fait peut-être plus de deux
victimes mais il a joué quand même dans
ce frein comme marc épidémie aujourd'hui
le confinement a été essentielle le
confinement c'est la sanction quand on
n'avait pas ce qu'il fallait c'est à
dire que parce qu'on n'avait pas un
masque parce qu'on n'a pas mis en place
de zones de fins de tests aléatoires
il nous a fallu mettre en place le
confinement et tous les pays qui ont
réussi à faire sortir entre guillemets
ont mis en place un test massif du
marquage systématique
clairement si on n'a pas encore compris
ça il faudra encore attendre d'une
épidémie puce
bon voilà mais s'il faut pas désespérer
1 ou 2 50 ou 60 ans on devrait commencer
à comprendre qu'il fera des stocks de
masques et qu'il faut les mettre en
distribution libre et que l'on doit voir
du gel hydroalcoolique dans les lieux de
rassemblement
mais j'ai pas encore vu de mesures qui
demande au lieu de rassemblement de
faire donc a priori je pense que pour la
prochaine fois on va pouvoir recommencer
le même cirque
alors justement les lieux de
rassemblement en même temps ils sont
interdits pour le moment en tout cas au
delà de 10 personnes vous trouvez que
c'est c'est encore sévère ou le danger
justement viendrait précisément de la de
rassemblement voilà rassemblé
rassemblement avec beaucoup de personnes
évidemment il faut effectivement se
rappeler quand même que les vilenies
partie du ce personne à l'origine d'un
quasi au même si têtu plusieurs casinos
en france
au démarrage mais c'était unique yannick
s'est répandue très vite happé
qu'effectivement on peut avoir des
résurgences ça se voit ça s'est déjà vu
c'est pas le cas le plus fréquent des
délits mais ça peut arriver et donc du
coup il faut rester effectivement
vigilant et on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des personnes qui sont des supers
contaminateur nous on a des lieux qui
sont des super content et donateurs et
dès que vous êtes en situation confine
et beaucoup pensent tout à fait un
commissariat on va penser aux transports
en commun
on va penser une voiture un train est
évident que il se propage à une très
grande rapidité et on a ou le sait la
rfa encore en paye armée il ya quelques
quelques heures des hommes de clusters
qu'ils sont honnêtement identifiés et
d'ailleurs qui ont été identifiés et je
m'en réjouis grâce à des tests
aléatoires dont deux pour le nord pas de
calais que j'ai réalisé dans mon propos
kevin et donc voilà on revient toujours
à la même la même stratégie pour tester
tester tester et isoler les personnes
positives
justement j'allais y venir catherine et
nous le disait l'épidémiologiste qu'on a
eu en invité il ya quelques minutes ils
disaient voilà il faut tester c'est là
la solution peut-être plutôt que
d'interdire les rassemblements de tester
à l'entrée de ces rassemblements que ce
soit des rassemblements privé public des
trains c'est selon vous une situation
fille à bhl pour éviter justement une
éventuelle propagation
alors maintenant comment on arrive enfin
défini par définition du nombre de tests
positifs est très faible
donc il va falloir vous êtes unis l'une
2000 tests pour réussir à avoir un seul
cas positif et donc il va falloir
beaucoup de persévérance et c'est le
moment où il faut être
à quoi s'accrocher avant pointilleux
pour continuer à tester alors qu'on a
l'impression de ne plus avoir aucun
bénéfice de ce test est fait je rappelle
que des trains tests aléatoires et
sûrement pas un test sous est
symptomatique puisqu'il faut l'isoler
immédiatement et fantomatique
on sait que aujourd'hui la majeure
partie de la contamination se fait dans
la phase non épidémique
et je rappelle puisque je vois à l'image
votre faux reportage qui ne faut pas
mettre le masque souvent comme on voit
très souvent effectivement donc les
tests effectivement l'application stop
qu'ovide edouard philippe s'est arrêté
quelques instants vantant les mérites de
cette application qui d'ailleurs a été
approuvé par les députés de l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine votre réaction
l'application stockée vite c'est
absolument fabuleux c'est exactement ce
qu'il nous fallait il ya six mois voilà
donc c'est bien on pourra s'en servir
pour la prochaine fois j'ai tant que les
gouvernements à se mettre en place
on arrive à avoir toutes les bonnes
mesures mais à la fin qui donne vraiment
l'impression d'avoir tout ce que luc
ferry
on a juste dit on l'est d'avignon comme
d'habitude mieux vaut tard que jamais on
va la tenter de conclure si tant est
qu'on puisse se faire dans ce genre de
sujet dramatique par une boutade un
petit peu plus légères merci à vous en
tout cas bertrand legrand d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
autres annonces attendues celles
concernant les écoles elles seront
toutes ouvertes en juin l'ensemble des
collèges rey aurait en zone verte avec
une réouverture progressive pour les
zones oranges écoutez les précisions du
ministre de l'éducation
l'ensemble des collèges vont désormais
ouvrir ce soit en zone verte ou en zone
orange en zone verte cela signifie donc
que l'on n'ajoute la 4e et la troisième
après la 6e et la cinquième qui ont déjà
ouvert donc l'ensemble des classes sont
ouvertes en zone verte entend en zone
orange
nous allons accueillir en priorité les
élèves de 6e et de 5e et si les
conditions matérielles sont réunies les
élèves des autres niveaux pourront
ensuite être accueilli
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
benjamin amar enseignants porte parole
cgt du val de marne bonsoir benjamin
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc toutes les familles qui le
souhaitent doivent pouvoir scolariser
leurs enfants au moins sur une partie de
la semaine a dit jean michel blanquer
toutes les écoles qui seront donc
ouvertes dans la phase de notre réaction
on imagine que vous n'êtes pas trop
content tels que je vous connais
benjamins à voir ce soir dans l'est
surtout d'une malhonnêteté incroyable
cet égard que c'est pas les familles qui
le souhaitent
c'est jean michel blanquer et vous savez
on a tous les sondages d'opinion les
sondages d'opinion montrent que les
français sont ultra majoritairement
contre la réouverture des écoles bien
conscient que les conditions de sécurité
sanitaire ne sont pas formés donc faire
croire que c'est qu'ils répondent à
comment dire aux desiderata des familles
c'est à hurler de rire c'est exactement
l'inversé les français voudraient que
comme en italie comme en espagne comme
dans l'état de new york
les et que la rentrée soit reportée en
septembre
voilà et cette décision elle est
complètement aberrante et elle est
marquée par une entêtement de plus en
plus absurde parce que ne vous a pas
échappé qu'à partir du mois de juin
enfin en principe en temps normal on
adjoint l'année scolaire et aux
quasiment terminé c'est le noir où
l'activité pédagogique est la plus
faible
un jour d'aujourd'hui il y a de 20 à 30
% des élèves qui ont été scolarisés en
france et la plupart du temps sur un
temps partiel donc ça veut dire que
l'année scolaire elle est fichue
voilà le coc vide a eu raison notre
activité économique aidant une raison de
l'activité pédagogique
on le sait très bien d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a annoncé que l'épreuve de
bac français se fera effectivement en
contrôle continu donc elle n'aurait pas
lieu donc à quoi ça rime devoir à tout
prix s'obstiner à la réouverture des
collèges et eddy et des lycées au mois
de juin le tout simplement pour faire
garderie voilà c'est ccxr garderie
pourrissent en espérant on pourra ainsi
organiser le retour au travail de
manière de manière la plus massive et
donc le gouvernement s'entête sur des
décisions aberrantes
benjamin amarres pour coiffer des
garderies vous avez un premier bilan
vraiment concret des premiers enfants
qui sont allés à l'école parce que selon
les témoignages de certains parents il
me semble que voilà certaines classes
ont la chance en tout cas d'avoir
retrouvé leur professeur qui tente quand
même de les remettre un petit peu on
celle de revoir le programme même si les
vrais voilà qu'on ne peut pas faire des
miracles enfin y en a tout simplement
qu'il travaille à l'école en ce moment
vous n'en prenez pas non pas du tout ça
c c c excusez moi mais c'est de la flûte
et de la bombarde la remontée du terrain
n'est pas du tout seul si les conditions
je vous rappelle que je suis enseignant
y aura donc en l'occurrence quand vous
avez un protocole sanitaire qui vous dit
qu'il faut quatre mètres carrés
effectivement au tour des enfants il ya
aucune salle de classe qui peut faire
effectivement vous permet d'avoir une
classe entière à 4 mètres carrés d'ombré
des petits groupes en réalité l'activité
pédagogique elle est complètement
tronqué déjà je voulais des les
pourcentages sont là c'est de 20 à 30%
des enfants qui ont été scolarisés sur
un temps partiel donc on n'est pas du
tout sur une activité pédagogique
normale est elle encore une fois ci si
c'était le cas eh bien on aurait
peut-être par exemple penser à maintenir
l'épreuve de maths français ce n'est pas
le cas donc faut arrêter de pardonnez
moi mais justement c'est pas plutôt pour
ceux qui ne sont pas à l'école que c'est
discriminant parce que ceux qui sont
acquis ont la chance peut-être d'être
scolarisés dans un petit groupe de 10 et
bientôt on sait qu'on apprend mieux a
dit ce quinqua 25,1 dans une salle de
classe est plutôt pour les autres qui ne
sont pas que qui est le problème
non excusez moi alors je veux bien que
vous retenir repreniez la litanie du
gouvernement sur le fait que non non je
reprends pas de litanies pardonnez-moi
mais voilà je parle à des parents je
suis maman moi même pour être honnête et
je vois effectivement ce qui se passait
sur la merci et moi je suis enseignant
madame et je vous le dis ce que vous
reprenez là c'est effectivement l'idée
que en réalité c'est pour lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire
mais si vous voulez je peux vous donnez
moi les chiffres du de la manière dont
le gouvernement a utilisé les moyens
contre le décrochage scolaire
moi je suis entré malades d'ailleurs je
voulais déjà dit dans une interview
précédente
je suis rentrée dans l'éducation comme
mes collègues pour lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire grandir cet argument
est bien c'est une c tout quelque chose
de totalement fallacieux voir et donc je
vous le dis très tranquillement nu il
n'y a pas d'activités pédagogiques
normal ça n'est pas vrai et d'ailleurs
encore une fois regarder les sondages
d'opinion ce que vous dites je suis
maman ben écoutez les mamans et les
papas ils sont sondés et regardez l'état
de l'opinion dont personne n'est dupe de
la manoeuvre est encore une fois on a
effectivement
des décisions qui sont totalement
contradictoires mais il n'ya pas que
dans l'éducation
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez aux pédiatres
qui ont publié une tribune assez fourni
c'est dans le quotidien du médecin avec
des pontes de la pédiatrie justement un
plan les enfants les parents à remettre
leurs enfants à l'école parce qu'il n'y
avait aucun risque qui n'était pas
vecteur de cette maladie qu'en général
quand il l'attrapé c'était par les
adultes vous leur répondez quoi
écoutez je leur réponds qu encore une
fois moi je veux bien
je veux bien qu'on ait ce débat en
france mais d'habitude on aime bien les
comparatifs européen
alors qu'est ce à dire dans les pays
dans tous les pays encore une fois où
nous avons des clusters d'épidémie
comparable à la france en espagne en
italie on a décidé de reporter en
septembre ça veut dire quoi
les pédiatres italiens espagnols ou les
enseignants italiens espagnols les
responsables politiques italiens
espagnols ce sont des inconséquent et
des inconscients
on va faire croire à qui que l'activité
pédagogique elle est importante dans les
dernières semaines de juin
honnêtement on attend dé moi je veux
bien mais il ya quand même encore
beaucoup de restrictions les lieux de
culture les lieux de spectacles sont
fermés enfin sauf le puy du fou parce
que c'est le fait du prince et que
monsieur devises y est visiblement un
proche de manuel macron mais il ya
encore beaucoup de restrictions y
compris de pour eux pour par exemple les
bars et les restaurants dans la zone
verte
donc on sait très bien madame vous savez
pertinemment parce qu'on a déjà débattu
que les conditions de sécurité sanitaire
dans les écoles elles sont pas du tout
comment dire anodine ni anecdotique ans
dans l'enseignement primaire ou dans les
collèges c'est très compliqué de faire
respecter à des groupes d'enfants les
règles de distanciation physique et ce
en ligne ça fait partie des motifs qui
font que dans l'état de new york en
espagne et en italie
on a décidé de reporter en septembre
donc je suis désolé je suis désolé pour
le pédiatre je suis désolé pour mes
cheveux blancs coeur me faire croire une
dernière petite question n'a jamais à
marc parent dont on parlait du bac
doral de français le contrôle continu
c'est une bonne chose pour vous qu on
juge sur quelques mois qu'on passe son
bac français ainsi attendait ya pas d
une question si les gars vous voulez
vous que je vous dise
il n'y a pas de ya pas de situation est
parfaite il ya pas de solution parfaite
bien évidemment bien évidemment que
est-ce que honnêtement les enseignants
comme moi est-ce qu'on est satisfait de
faire des cours à distance et de ne pas
pouvoir voir mon élève de ne pas pouvoir
effectivement faire cours dans des
conditions normales est ce qu'on n'est
pas conscient qu'il y ait une fracture
numérique
bien évidemment mais il n'y avait pas de
solution parfaite il fallait
effectivement se résoudre à ce que cette
année soit pédagogiquement une année à
part dans la baie en septembre
l'épidémie sera derrière nous puisque
visiblement il ya la deuxième vague et
on travaillera effectivement on mettra
les bouchées doubles et montant total
sera effectivement de 2,2 de compenser
ce qui s'est passé mais s'obstine et
encore une fois on a 2 juin alors que
l'année pédagogique elle est terminée
qu'elle est effectivement grande partie
impactés et bien alors que encore une
fois vous savez je vais vous dire je
voulais déjà dit mais c'est pas grave
c'est la pédagogie de la répétition chez
les enseignants en réalité dans bon
nombre des peules ce sont les
enseignants qui ont dû eux mêmes tout
mettre en place
parce que rien n'était mis à leur
disposition parce qu'il y avait on a
balancé la pâte est que la patate chaude
au maire sans qu'ils aient les moyens
adéquats pour pouvoir y répondre
voilà c'est ça la réalité et c'est pour
ça qu'il ya beaucoup de familles qui
constatant cela ou prédisant ceux là
n'ont pas mis leur enfant à l'école et
ils ont bien eu raison parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'il
n'ya pas eu de deuxième vague mais qui
pouvait le prévoir
c'est le sens même du principe de
précaution qui est un principe
constitutionnel
voilà donc je pense qu'on devrait aller
jusqu'au bout et donc reportée en
septembre
merci benjamin marre d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france porte
parole cgt duval demain mercier bout la
gestion de la crise sanitaire toufik ben
derbal ex-collaborateurs d'olivier veron
est visé par une enquête pour trafic
d'influencé il est soupçonné d'avoir
cherché là ni mars à positionner une
offre de masques ffp2 auprès du
ministère de la santé afin de toucher
une commission d'enquêté en cours entre
le mis-en-cause qui a
reconnu les faits les détails avec mona
hamou dès lors c'est une enquête qui
embarrasse le ministère de la santé qui
permet d'en savoir un peu plus sur les
agissements de certains collaborateurs
en coulisses tewfik derbal ex
collaborateur d'olivier vers ans est
visé par une enquête pour trafic
d'influencé
après avoir tenté de toucher une
commission sur une livraison de masques
ffp2 d'une société d'import-export alors
que le pays connaissait une pénurie en
la matière tout commence en mars alors
que la pandémie de kovy 19 se répand en
europe
une société française d'import export
avec la chine se tourne vers ses
fournisseurs locaux et trouvent un
débouché des masques ffp2 la société
entre donc en contact avec théophile
derbal l'ex collaborateur du ministre de
la santé
d'après médiapart le 16 mars l'ex
assistant parlementaire répond
rapidement aux sollicitations de la
société je suis en lien avec la personne
qui gère cette situation au sein du
ministère
je voulais savoir comment vous procédez
habituellement avec les apporteurs
d'affaires au lendemain de cette
conversation durban tandis que les
autorités sont intéressés par les
masques proposés et formule une demande
je vous joins un contrat d'apporteur
d'affaires accompagnée d'un avenant afin
de valider notre collaboration
vous n'avez plus qu'à compléter la
commission en pourcentage qui me revient
et signer le contrat et l'avenant il
faut préciser qu 1,2 million de masques
étaient proposées et d'après les
éléments récoltés par mediapart elle
file des rebelles a réclamé 2 % du prix
sur chaque masque vendu la société lui
explique que ce n'est pas l'usagé en
matière d'import export car cela
impliquerait une hausse du prix du
masque le faisant passer de 2 euros 60
pièces à 2,066 un contrat est donc
proposé indiquant à théophile derbal qui
touchera une commission interrogée par
mediapart
celui ci nie d'abord puis devant les
éléments présentés fini par concéder
qu'il s'était dit pourquoi pas
expliquant que la société avait proposé
cette commission je lui ai pas dit au
fait moi je veux une commission je
connais des gens par téléphone il nous a
fait part d'un possible remerciements si
la transaction avait lieu
j'avais déjà ma société j'ai dit
pourquoi pas j'ai seulement souhaité
faire les choses en bonne et due forme
en proposant un contrat
il m'a ouvert une porte automatique mans
j'y suis entré pourtant selon les
éléments récoltés par mediapart c'est
bien des rebelles qui aborde le sujet de
cette commission
et c'est encore lui qui transmet un
contrat d'apporteur d'affaires à remplir
et réclame avec insistance 2% du prix
sur chaque masque vendus selon mediapart
le contrat a été signé entre les deux
parties mais la transaction n'a jamais
eu lieu
le mis en cause a depuis reconnu les
faits et d'après bfmtv tewfik derbal a
été placé en garde à vue puis relâchés
de son côté olivier ferrand a indiqué
que cette histoire ne le concernent et
pas le parquet de paris a donc ouvert
une enquête préliminaire pour trafic
d'influencé commis par un particulier à
un délit passible de 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et 500000 euros damende
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons aux états unis où donald
trump menace de fermer le réseau social
twitter qui a ajouté une mise en garde à
ses messages
et puis direction l'espace avec le
premier vol habité de la firme space x
entreprises d'elon musk sous la tutelle
de la nasa
le décollage de la fusée a été reportée
à sa demie en raison du mauvais temps
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intervention
dans la crise du coc vite 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
qui est responsable du fiasco
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avoir la triste
absence du stop requis la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus est l'état providence que nous
avons que pour anne aura été cimetière
de certaines espérances en pensant que
progrès peser de nous des hommes dieu et
que les technocrates avec les du monde
de demain les conséquences de la crise
oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que tous les pays
de la planète décide finalement de
sacrifier leurs économies pour sauver
des vies humaines
bien sûr c'est sauver des vies mais
c'est aussi conservé l'appareil
productif et permettent que ceux qui
sont dans les secteurs essentiels ceux
qui sont essentiels à l'économie du pays
puissent continuer aussi à travailler
dans le même temps diriez-vous de
l'économie française est dans une
situation catastrophique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que toutes les
planètes sont pas encore alignée pour
qu'on puisse absolument se dire qu'on va
réussir à surmonter de la meilleure
manière possible cette crise j'imagine
que l'initiative franco allemande
s'inscrit dans rock dans votre logique
les 500 milliards c'est une enveloppe il
ya un peu une enveloppe en termes de
communication pour l'instant ce n'est un
engagement oui mais ça veut pas dire que
rabat contrepartie croire que cette clé
du coc vide aurait effacé les handicaps
que nous portions en france fait croire
qu'on va pouvoir repartir à zéro sans
régler les problèmes d'hier et c'est une
erreur
[Musique]
pour recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis puni
par renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck faire que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire les bêtes des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent
jamais en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
21h 21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france à
donald trump doit donc signer ce jeudi
un décret visant les réseaux sociaux
cette décision intervient quelques
heures après que le président américain
est menacée de réguler ou de fermer les
entreprises du secteur
retour sur la relation entre le
président américain et twitter en images
[Musique]
on
twitter s'immisce maintenant dans
l'élection présidentielle de 2020 ils
disent que ma déclaration sur le vote
par correspondance qui va conduire à une
corruption et une fraude massive est
incorrect en se basant sur une
vérification des faits par cnn fausses
nouvelles et l'amazone washington post
twitter étouffe complètement la liberté
d'expression et moi en tant que
président je ne permettrai pas que cela
se produise
[Musique]
mais pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis new york avec caleb maupin
journaliste politique pour rt america
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir qu'elle est bonne pas un merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
réseau social en l'occurrence twitter
qui défient le président américain il
faut quand même une certaine audace
n'aide pas wendy oui le plus tard
l'étiquette c'est les déclarations du
président sur twitter qui tente qui a
une vision que ne sont pas fondées et
remettez en question sur qui la filme
bien sûr donald trump et la maison
blanche longue ça a pris tellement
donald trump et beaucoup de
conservateurs aux états unis qu'il ya
une pression aux états unis depuis les
élections 2016
il ya beaucoup d'efforts afin de
contrôler les informations qu'ils
allaient à l'encontre du récit du
discours libéral dans les pays
occidentaux capitaliste et que ces
efforts avaient mené un billet politique
qui a contre les conservateurs aux états
unis alors les menaçant de donald trump
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs même un décret
qui vise les réseaux sociaux il aimerait
on plaire faire fermer twitter est ce
que vraiment ça paraît réaliste que
donald trump puisse aller jusqu'au bout
évoqué la possibilité de tweeter
mais cela serait assez complexe heures
suivant la constitution américaine
le département de la justice américain
étudie le la question de savoir si
google apple twitter ou facebook fonte à
l'encontre des lois antimonopoles ni aux
états unis car mais pas vraiment de
compétition dans ce domaine et si le
travail en tant que monopole alors il
n'y a aucun aucune façon de pouvoir les
décrire en tant que compagnie
qu'entreprises privées qu'ils sont
utilisé cet argument pour dire qu'il
s'agissait de ceinture donc il s'agirait
alors d'une violation de la liberté
d'expression mais c'est aux entreprises
ont utilisé le marché libre en tant que
défense mais aujourd'hui ils sont
essentiels l'énergie américaine ne peut
pas vous retirez l'électricité ou
d'autres entreprises ne peuvent pas vous
couper l'eau si vous avez émis des
opinions qui leur déplaisent et beaucoup
de personnes considèrent que c'est la
même chose avec twitter et facebook car
il s'agit de monopole donc on ne peut
pas éviter justement c'était ma
prochaine question est ce que twitter
est pour ainsi dire sorti de son rôle
est finalement fait de la politique
depuis 2016 il y à un barrage dans les
réseaux sociaux de nantes à twitter ou à
facebook de lutter contre les théories
du complot aux états unis mais lorsqu'on
entre dans les détails
la situation devient très complexe si
quelqu'un propose une opinion
alternative par exemple on sent la clé
mais considère qu'il s'agit d'une
théorie du complot même si la personne
n'évoque que des faits prouvés
donald trump récemment à soulever
certaines questions sur le réseaux
sociaux concernant joe scarborough
on a considéré qu'il s'agissait d'une
théorie du complot mais la première
personne avoir évoqué le sujet n'était
pas un conservateur ou une personne de
droite c'était michael moore ce
réalisateur tient
reçu plusieurs récompenses il parlait de
laurie classe houthis une assistante de
drayton qui est morte dans des
circonstances mystérieuses
hélas que je n'attends plus mais on
parle alors il s'agit d'une théorie du
complot
il y a et beaucoup de billets facebook
ou de vidéos sur youtube ont été
supprimés donc pourquoi une entreprise
privée des personnes qui n'ont pas été
élus
pourquoi ces personnes auraient-elles
l'autorité de considérer qu'il s'agit de
théories du complot dans certains cas et
dans notre cas de questions légitimes
cela semble injuste notamment vu qu'ils
n'ont pas été élus donc ces personnes de
plus sont plutôt en faveur du parti
démocrate il ya beaucoup de liberta
risque dans la silicon valley tu
néolibéralisme et de l'économie de la
libre entreprise mais ils sont plus
démocrate que républicain
hillary clinton était très proche d'eric
schmidt et mark zuckerberg est très
proche de beaucoup de grandes figures du
parti démocrate
donc beaucoup de mains très important
que les partis conservateurs pensent
qu'il y à une injustice et cela
s'applique également sélection justement
quel est le mot pas vous parler des
élections ces menaces interviennent dans
le chai à cinq mois de la présidentielle
beaucoup de choses vont se jouer sur les
réseaux sociaux on imagine que c'est un
enjeu majeur
évidemment tout à fait beaucoup
d'américains près leurs décisions en
fonction de ce qu'il voit par exemple
sur facebook ou twitter ou sur internet
en général
si les géants technologiques de la ccog
vallée sont un monopole et qu'en plus on
beaucoup d' influence politique et sont
partiaux envers les démocrates alors
beaucoup de personnes disent qu'il ya
une injustice flagrante
ils peuvent effectivement influencer
l'opinion de plusieurs millions de
personnes et donc leur vote
donald trump at il la possibilité
d'aller à l'encontre de cela au niveau
constitutionnel cela reste à voir
car effectivement il s'agit
théoriquement d'entreprises privées
cependant même le département de la
justice se remet en question un
situation et twitter a accusé le
président des états unis de propager des
théories du complot et encourage les
gens à ne pas le croire et pour beaucoup
de personnes
c'est un comportement complètement
inapproprié merci qu'elle aime aux pains
jeunesse politique pour rta merika
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir en direct
des états unis et aurait justement aux
etats unis deuxième journée de violences
consécutives à minneapolis après la mort
d'un afro américain lors de son
interpellation par la police était lundi
dernier
depuis la ville du minnesota ne cesse de
s'embraser des émeutes qui touche
également d'autres villes du pays
pierre pissavy yvernault depuis deux
jours minneapolis est le théâtre de
scènes violentes entre forces de l'ordre
et manifestants
les mouvements de protestation contre le
meurtre de george floyd et 46 cents par
des policiers se multiplient
le maire et le gouverneur du minnesota
tente de calmer la situation
s'il vous plaît minneapolis nous ne
pouvons pas laisser la tragédie engendré
plus de tragédies la zone le long du lac
est devenue dangereuse
nous demandons votre aide pour maintenir
la paix ce soir la situation près de
l'extrémité i à watts à minneapolis est
devenue une situation extrêmement
dangereuse pour la sécurité de tous
veuillez quitter la zone et autoriser
les pompiers et les ambulanciers
paramédicaux à se rendre sur les lieux
c'est donc une vidéo de l'arrestation
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux qui met
le feu aux poudres en début de semaine
on y voit john floyd agonisant sur le
sol sous le genou d'un policier et
supplier pour qu'on lui laisse la vie
sauve à la colère voilà donc le
sentiment qui règne aujourd'hui dans les
rues de minneapolis c'est le pire
passage à tabac de la police de tous les
temps et je dis toujours que je ne peux
rien voir de pire que les coûts de
rodney king
c'est pire que rodney king dans le
contexte de cet homme
francs pendant 9 minutes nous devons
nous rassembler rester unis ce n'est pas
normal
nous sommes en 2020 le virus ne tue la
police nous tue le gouvernement n'aide
personne
pour l'avocat de la famille de georges
floyd rien ne peut justifier un tel
comportement
si vous avez un téléphone portable vous
le prenez vous réglez votre chronomètre
sur neuf minutes vous vous asseyez vous
laisser le temps passé et à ce moment là
vous imaginez quelqu'un avec son genou
contre votre coup alors que vous vous
débattez pour pouvoir respirer alors que
personne ne fait rien pour que vous
puissiez respirer et bien tout ça ce
sont les dernières minutes de la vie de
georges floyd en un mot c'est un meurtre
il n'y a rien qui justifie cela en ce
qui concerne le gouvernement justement à
donald trump lui aussi a réagi le
président américain demande l'ouverture
d'une enquête
à ma demande le fbi et le ministère de
la justice ont déjà entamé une enquête
sur la mort très tristes et tragiques de
john floyd au minnesota
c'est donc une affaire qui en rappellent
d'autres aux états unis depuis plusieurs
années les victimes noires sous les
coups de policier blanc se multiplient
aujourd'hui les quatre policiers
responsables de la mort de georges floyd
ont été renvoyés les autorités locales à
vous aujourd'hui vouloir mettre tout en
oeuvre pour faire la lumière sur cette
terrible tragédie
le suspense continue de décollage de la
navette spatial space x a été reporté
hier en raison des conditions
climatiques
orages vents et risque de foudre la
prochaine tentative aura lieu samedi à
19 heures 22 heures françaises space x
marque le début d'une nouvelle ère dans
laquelle les états unis confie pour la
première fois au secteur privé le
transport de ses astronautes pourront
parler de ce premier vol habité à bord
d'une fusée space x et nous sommes en
direct avec patrick baudry spatiaux nos
deuxièmes français est reparti dans
l'espace merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france patrick baudry
qui on le rappelle a effectué une
mission de sept jours en 85 à bord de la
navette discovery
michel polacco à ses côtés journalistes
spécialistes aéronautiques merci à vous
aussi à michel polacco d'être en direct
alors déception au hier évidemment on
était tous suspendus à nos écrans vexé
ces deux astronautes habillé en héros
américains et finalement pas ça a été
annulé alors pour le grand public qui ne
sait pas tout patrick braud de baudry on
rappelle que ces fenêtres de tir sont
sont très réduites et sont très
sensibles bien évidemment à la météo
bien sûr il ya une fenêtre en temps qui
est serrée puisque c'est une question de
positionnement par rapport à la station
et ensuite la maison c'est toujours un
problème pour tous les armements aux
états unis en floride
la météo est parfois très délicate avec
des orages et c'est comme ça quelqu'un
encore et donc c'est là mais gagner le
monde j'ai eu plus de dix autres
annulations aux tirs donc ça me rappelle
des souvenirs
c'est pas très grave au fond du tiercé
absolument pas l'heure mais alors
justement patrick baudry parce qu'on
rejoue je mourrai dedans vie de leur
poser la question hier donc j'en profite
avec vous j'ai cette chance ce soir
qu'est ce qu'on ressent pas ce qu'on
imagine une pression terrible quand on
est dans cette navette qu'on aime tant
voilà de dette
propulsé et puis à 3 minutes on nous
annule qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on ressent
est ce qu on est préparé à ça j'ai quand
même un peu oui bien sûr non retour on
ressent une grande frustration puisque
on espère toujours partir le compte à
rebours s'égrène pour ne sais pas avec
rené savelli de fortes chances de ne pas
partir et bien voulu la météo mais même
mur - on se prépare on va en quarantaine
pendant une semaine deux semaines et
donc on attend la véhémence en fait et
lorsque ça ne part pas et bien c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas évident à la
vibration du bien parce que le choix de
poser les problèmes sinon d'être mais
néanmoins voilà moi ça m amuse et de
mémoire en pyjama ccsa modern dance a
beaucoup changé washita surtout un
admirateur de nos masques de spécifier
de la fadq animal même source le fait
moment des arrestations ccb résultat
d'une grande importance
ce que j'attends c'est qu'on envoie des
touristes un kit haider leur voyage en
orbite basse parce que leur big ben a
sonné professionnel je suis ça vraiment
ridicule en devenir mais celle pour les
coppola qu on a beaucoup parlé d'une
nouvelle ère so ques historique
d'abord je sais du bruit patrick baudry
qui évidemment lui a eu l'honneur et le
bonheur de voler dans l'espace
le risque c'est une nouvelle ère quelque
part oui d'abord le retour des
américains dans l'espace après qu'ils
aient fait quand même la conquête de la
lune c'est obligatoirement un événement
deuxièmement ça fait dix ans que les
russes sont ce monopole
les chinois aussi avait la possibilité
de le faire mais il n'en menaient pas
d'étranger et donc ça veut dire que les
russes devaient avoir un problème de
finance et de rentabilisation de refuser
leur vaisseau soyouz
troisièmement on attaque une nouvelle
phase de la conquête spatiale puisque là
ce sont des entreprises privées puisque
l'as sp6 d'elon musk qui au passage vous
rappelle a amené ses astronautes hier
soir au pâtir l 39 à qu'était le pas de
tir des fusées apollo avec une voiture
tesla les tesla est donc c'est ce sont
des entreprises privées spécifique c'est
boeing qui vont se retrouver en
concurrence d'ailleurs avec les russes
et avec les chinois et on sait que le
prochain objectif c'est pas comme le
disait patrick baudry tourner autour de
la terre dans la station orbitale
internationale
le prochain objectif c'est d'aller sur
l'ale de retourner sur la lune et
ensuite de partir à la conquête du monde
sidéral de mars des astéroïdes et
d'autres places de l'espace qui attise
notre curiosité et qui sont évidemment
génétiquement chez l'homme des lieux qui
nous intrigue et qu'on a envie de
découvrir ça vous semble justement
réaliste patrick baudry qu'on en arrive
là parce que évidemment c'est l'objectif
que poursuit elon musk que poursuit
aussi richard branson
même s'il a un petit peu freiné ses
ardeurs ces derniers temps on rappelle
quand même que c'est un effort de 18 ans
il ya quand même eu des fusées qui se
sont crashés space x et enfin on arrive
à quelque chose donc le tourisme spatial
c'est pour demain selon vont bien sûr
mais je suis très heureuse d'entendre un
jeune français michel dire que
l'objectif c'est mars et au dollar alors
que ton à en trente ans les a
complètement occulté ces genres de de
target
alors le doigt est le masque homme qui
était vraiment un génie et qui a une
réussite absolument extraordinaire la
falc online c'est un lanceur vraiment
magique et je suis non pas s'attendre
jamais l'être mais j'espère que et le
must pour atteindre son objectif qui est
mars envoyer quelqu'un de sion mars est
donc tout ça oui on va le voir dans les
années qui viennent alors retourner sur
la lune dont vous m'avez tous liste
faire le tour de la lune tout ça on
verra
et il reviendra cette station cette
station spatiale afin que le dit yves
notre comité se fait pas mal de temps et
donc c'est le début d'une nouvelle ère
avec de la technologie vraiment plus
qu'une plus performante que je réutilise
meilleures années et le fait que la nasa
qui est quand même une administration un
peu un peu mollassonne je dirais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a dit ruff un
administrateur mana il ya un an remonter
les bretelles indirecte le produit
encore jeunes n'avaient pas de dire que
continuer à aller là 400 km de la terre
ça c'était bien vu beaucoup la pression
est donc les administrations ou
deviennent un petit peu incompétente
n'iront pas assez compétente et donc
c'est le privé qui attaque qui prend la
relève avec des gens comme mince que
manson et c est donc c'est vraiment le
début d'une nouvelle ère chinarro aller
plus vite moins cher plus loin les plus
sûres et justement on l'appelle souvent
cette fusée low cost qui manifestement
on le comprend dans vos propres et mieux
voilà en termes de rapport qualité prix
que que la nasa vous parliez également
d'apollo quelle différence entre le crew
dragan et la capsule apollo on imagine
que tout est changé dans la cabine tout
a été évidemment moderniser un poids
qu'on n'imagine pas michel polacco
évidemment il s'est pas dit il s'est
écoulé 50 ans vous imaginez bien quand
on a fait du chemin
toutefois le principe de la capsule
puisque vous parliez de navettes tout à
l'heure donc la navette elle est
abandonnée navette spatiale et par lord
of contrevenu à des capsules qui sont au
bout de fusée en eau et qui ensuite
reviennent sur terre accroché sur des
parachutes sous des parachutes et se
pose sur la terre ferme ou dans l'eau et
donc ce sont des calculs qui sont sous
cet angle là tout à fait classique et
traditionnelle avec un bouclier
thermique pour pouvoir revenir dans
l'atmosphère avec un espace souvent un
peu réduit bien que là le crew dragon
est fait pour accueillir jusqu'à sept
personnes a donc un mc portable que ne
l'était apollo qui ne pouvait en
accueillir que 3 et c'était quand même
très serré comme d'ailleurs le soyouz de
jean chrétien compère de patrick baudry
qui quand vous le voyez quand vous
imaginez ce qu'ils étaient ces pauvres
trois cosmonautes serrés comme des
saucisses et quelquefois pour 48 heures
et ça a été plus long même pour d'autres
d'ailleurs enfin bon là c'est plus
confortable
c'est plus large ils sont mieux
installés ils sont mieux climatisé
ils ont évidemment des instruments de
pilotage de navigation qui sont plus
modernes
enfin ça c'est relativement simple et
rustique quand même et ça marche très
bien et il n'ya pas des choses très
complexe à faire donc non c'est pas tout
ça on est en train de mettre en å de
fusée qui sont comme les fusées 75
d'apollo des capsules qui sont comme les
capsule apollo du programme apollo
quelque part 50 ans après on peut pas
dire que tu es une révolution il n'y a
pas eu de révolution patrick godet
beaudry pardon on disait quand même
comme oui allez via les et l'évolution
quand même très très bon c'est un peu
comme si l'on comparé la bombe est là et
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
en ce qui concerne l'espace habité on
voit des hommes dans l'espace
on est resté avec la 4l à rien c'est
pratiquement la souris mini shell
pendant pendant 30 ans et ses deux ailes
drink que j'aime beaucoup et qui était
un ami très dynamique très proches
savaient le deuxième homme à avoir
marché sur la lune qui à dire pendant
l'interview au mois de juillet dernier
qui a dit de sa c30 ans on se fait
honteux il a dit hey trump est triste
hélas que trump ou remonter les
bretelles de l'administrateur de la nasa
je crois qu'il faudrait savoir une chose
avec des agences française et européenne
cnes il a c'est vraiment la belle au
bois dormant
alors ces deux astronautes auront leurs
appels américains vont rejoindre quand
même deux russes et un autre américain
on parle toujours de deux guerres en
vous me disiez les russes qui domine et
voilà que ce sont des américains qui
vont peut-on imaginer même si ce sont
des privés américains qui mènent ces
projets voilà qu'on ce qu'on se
rassemble dans un projet avec les russes
les chinois les américains où ça va
vraiment devenir une une guerre une
course à l'espace michel polacco course
c'est sûr guerre je ne crois pas d'abord
depuis apollo soyouz et la rencontre
dans l'espace des russes et des
américains
il ya une belle coopération et patrick
vous le dira mieux que moi il a des très
bons amis cosmonautes russes
il a des très bons copains astronautes
américains et je ne doute pas qu'ils
connaissent aussi quelques taïkonautes
chinois et ce sont des gens qui se
fréquente qui travaillent ensemble les
administrations travaillent ensemble
avec les européens aussi et globalement
c'est pas la guerre maintenant qui est
de la concurrence c'est certain et j'ai
un ami qui les a pas longtemps si les
américains ne sont pas sur la lune en
il y aura des restaurants sur la
chinoise sur la lune en 2026
c'était assez drôle parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même une vraie
compétition que pour lachine démontré sa
capacité et ses compétences
seule elle a bénéficié de l'aide des
russes pendant longtemps mais seuls
aujourd'hui pour partir à la conquête du
cosmos et quelque chose
très important politiquement donc oui à
une compagnie une compétition c'est
indiscutable est ce que ces gens
pourront travailler ensemble rassemblés
leur budget leur compte connaissance
dans certains domaines c'est sûr dans
tous les domaines certainement pas
n'oubliez pas que aussi l'espace
militaire et l'espace militaire ça ne se
partage pas patrick baudry le mot de la
fin sur ce thème justement les
américains emmenés par la main et nous
faire des cadeaux donc au niveau au
niveau des as sont donc bien sûr il ya
absolument aucun problème
on s'entend comme ans comme frères et
soeurs et on a des procédures qui sont
extrêmement rigoureuses qu'il faut
respecter
donc on a d'autres problèmes que les
problèmes politiques mais sur un
politique
je ne crois absolument pas que les
américains les russes et des chinois
dans la malle pour conquérir mars quoi
que ce soit déjà la lune va être quelque
chose extrêmement intéressant comme
depuis déjà plusieurs dizaines d'années
encore puisque on va y trouver des
ressources extrêmement importante et ça
m'étonnerait que les américains et les
chinois à partager le gâteau
donc les dix années qui viennent vont
être vraiment très hésitante au delà de
l'aspect purement technique et chez
l'autre la conquête spatiale repartent
ça va être pour la complète
oui nous aussi évidemment merci patrie
bobrie merci michel polacco d'avoir
répondu à nos questions directes sur rt
et puis voilà on suivra ça évidemment
samedi avec attention merci à tous les
deux et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera dans quelques minutes le 22
heures pour un résumé complet notamment
cette phase ii du confinement présenté
par edouard philippe ce soir
[Musique]
on est allé faire ailleurs ce qu'on
pouvait faire chez nous mais qui coûtait
trop cher à faire chez nous avons
aujourd'hui des usines qui ferment en
france pour se mettre dans les pays de
l'est en pologne en roumanie ailleurs
selon vous sa nou lé trop loin dans la
mondialisation
le principal problème c'est c'est aussi
l'europe et l'euro on est allé trop loin
surtout dans la désindustrialisation de
pays en france on trouve pas mal de
choses sauf que ça ne passe jamais dans
l'industrie ça pourrait créer des
emplois ça pourrait créer de la
croissance mais nous on recherche pour
la beauté de la recherche avant tout le
problème pour moi c'est la méfiance
globale de notre pays à l'égard
industriels il faut soutenir les
industriels c'est pas les intellectuels
de bersillon de dire comment l'industrie
succès les industriels qui me parle de
ça moi et qu'il au front
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intégration
dans la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
qui est responsable du fiasco
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avouer la triste
absence du stop revit la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus est l'état providence que nous
avons que pour anne aura été cimetière
de certaines espérances en pensant que
le progrès faisait de nous des hommes
dieu et que les technocrates avec les du
monde de demain les conséquences de la
crise oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile où chaque jour en
politique des milliers de parties
d'échecs sont joués mais les règles ne
sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france disparition des
limitations des 100 km réouverture des
restaurants et bars à partir du 2 juin
par tous temps partout en zone verte en
terrasse seulement en revanche en jaune
orange les ouvertures pourraient si des
collèges lycées en zone orange également
et annulation du bas chorale de français
c'est en substance ce qu'il faut retenir
de la phase 2 du déconfinement
présentait ce soir par edouard philippe
qui s'est lui une situation
fruit du bon travail de tous les
soignants ainsi que de la rigueur de
tous les français
troisième passe ce sera le 22 juin
le torchon brûle entre donald trump et
twitter le président américain multiplie
les menaces à l'encontre du réseau
social qui a pris la décision d'ajouter
une mise en garde ces messages
véhiculant des informations non
vérifiées après avoir menacé de
réglementer ferme et twitter le
locataire de la maison blanche va signer
aujourd'hui un décret dont le contenu
demeure encore inconnue trois jours
après la mort d'un infra méricain tué
par des policiers lors d'une arrestation
la ville de minneapolis aux états unis
s'embrase deuxième jour consécutif des
heurts entre des manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre les autorités locales
appellent au calme un taux net rump lui
demande une enquête du ministère de la
justice et du fbi hague
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
si vous nous rejoignez pour cette demi
heure d'information plus d'une heure
d'allocutions donc pour le premier
ministre entouré des ministres de
l'éducation et de la santé pour
présenter la phase 2 du déconfinement
les précisions depuis matignon de notre
reporter thomas boni
les nouvelles sont bonnes voilà une des
premières phrases qui a déclaré edouard
philippe lors de son allocution cet
après midi le premier ministre qui
explique que la propagation du virus est
sous contrôle raison pour laquelle cette
deuxième phase du déconfinement vois un
certain nombre de règles s'assouplir
l'une des plus emblématiques de ces
règles c'est celle des 100 km
interdiction de déplacement au delà de
100 km sauf motif impérieux et bien
cette mesure est désormais supprimée
elle n'avait plus de raison d'être selon
le premier ministre
en france comme je l'expliquais même si
certains déplacement nécessite encore
une vigilance importante
la tension est globalement moindre qu'au
début du déconfinement la mesure
d'interdiction de déplacement de plus de
100 km a été très utile durant ces trois
dernières semaines pour limiter la
propagation du virus
elle a été bien respecté par les
français je les en remercie mais
aujourd'hui avec la pression qui a
baissé
cette mesure n'a plus de justification à
compter du 2 juin
il est donc mis fin à l'interdiction de
déplacement de plus de 100 kilomètres de
chez soi autres grandes annonces du
premier ministre elle concerne la carte
du déconfinement il n'y a plus désormais
de département en zone rouge l'ensemble
du territoire et en zone verte à
l'exception notable des départements de
la région ile-de-france de la guyane et
de mayotte pour ces départements et bien
l'assouplissement des règles va se faire
de façon différenciée illustration par
exemple avec la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants elle pourrait être
effectué sur l'ensemble du territoire à
partir du 2 juin mais dans les zones
oranges
seuls les terrasses de ces bars ou de
ses restaurants pourront accueillir les
clients de nous
et puis concernant les parcs et jardins
ou encore les plages ces lieux seront
rouverts dès le 2 juin sur l'ensemble du
territoire différenciation entre zones
vertes et jaunes orange en revanche
encore concernant les établissements
scolaires les collèges vont être
rouverts de façon complète dans les
zones vertes ce ne sera qu'une
réouverture partielle dans les zones
oranges et puis en ce qui concerne les
lycées il y aura une ouverture
progressive on notera également que jean
michel blanquer a annoncé que l'oral de
français pour l'épreuve du baccalauréat
se ferait sur la base du contrôle
continu autre exemple de cette
différenciation selon les zones vertes
où orange elle concerne les salles de
spectacle les gymnases ou encore les
piscines qui pourront rouvrir à partir
du 2 juin dans les zones vertes situera
que à partir du 22 juin dans les zones
oranges le 22 juin c'est aussi la date
qui a été choisi pour la réouverture des
cinémas cette fois sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour justifier cet
assouplissement des règles
edouard philippe avance évidemment
l'argument de la propagation du virus
qui est désormais moins forte qu'elle
n'a pu l'être par le passé mais il ya
aussi une urgence économique la france
est face à une récession historique ce
sont les mots du premier ministre qui a
également évoqué les chiffres du chômage
parues aujourd'hui on écoute les
chiffres présentés par pôle emploi ce
matin la teste essonne l'urgence le
nombre de personnes inscrites à pôle
emploi qui n'ont pas travaillé du tout
en avril a augmenté de plus de 800
milles par rapport à mars
c'est malheureusement historique malgré
cet assouplissement généralisée des
mesures sanitaires edouard philippe en
appelle encore à la vigilance de tout et
de tous il a d'ailleurs rappelé que la
mise en service de l'application stop
qu'ovide sera prochainement effectuer
elle permettra de retracer les
différents contacts entre les personnes
atteintes par le
19 en attendant edouard philippe en
appel à l'esprit de responsabilité des
français et rendez vous est d'ores et
déjà pris pour le 22 juin le 22 juin qui
marque la date de la troisième phase de
confinement et edouard philippe a
également annoncé la réouverture des
restaurants et bars ou conditions pour
les régions orange écouter compte tenu
de l'évolution de la crise sanitaire les
restaurants bars et cafés pourront
ouvrir dans tous les départements à
partir du 2 juin mais ils ouvriront avec
des restrictions temporaires dans ceux
qui se trouvent dans les zones oranges
là où une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire les personnes qui ont choisi
de dîner ou de déjeuner ensemble
pourront s'asseoir à la même table dans
la limite d'une capacité maximale de 10
par table mais il devrait y avoir une
distance minimale d'un mètre entre les
tables de chaque groupe dans les
départements qui font l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière les départements
de l'île de france
mayotte et la guyane seuls les terrasses
des cafés et des bars et des restaurants
pourront ouvrir au 2 juin
cette réouverture un véritable
soulagement forcément pour les
restaurateurs c'est le cas notamment à
bordeaux écouter ça fait plaisir
d'entendre deux salles après des mois un
peu dur et puis et on est content de
pouvoir retrouver le client
le savoir qu'on va pouvoir travailler la
donne
condition que son twitter
acceptable et la situation aurait
organise les tables on met des marquages
au sol pour les clients on condamne une
partie des toilettes
les urinoirs on a beaucoup de
l'affichage qui sont regardés sur les
murs et ce après ça on voit que sur eux
mêmes sur l'emporter à le déconfinement
là qu'on aille à partir du 11 mai
c'était pas non plus
non plus gros boum pas donc
je pense que les gens manquent de soleil
mais en étant fier parce qu'elle nous
c'est président génie paris ile de
france et jean pierre pinelli vice
président du cercle des grandes maisons
corses nous ont fait part de leurs
réactions également les ouvrir pour nous
c'est retrouver nos clients remettent
des collaborateurs au travail donc ça va
dans le bon sens et cette situation
depuis le 15 mars devenait intenable sur
le plan humain économique être coupé
notre métier notre passion ça devenait
compliqué maintenant on est bien
conscient que c'est une demi-mesure on
aurait espéré comme nos collègues de
province passer au vert et ré ouvrir
plus largement
aujourd'hui beaucoup de restaurateurs ne
dispose pas de terrasse et je tiens à
préciser notamment pour la région ile de
france et pour paris que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui les conditions
administratives d'extension de nos
terrasses et donc aucun restaurateurs ne
plus aujourd'hui s'adresser à la mairie
et dire je souhaiterais rajouter les
tables et table à tel endroit
ce qui nous importe c'est évident nous
les professionnels c'est d'abord c'est
cette notion descendent kilomètres qu'il
me parlait c'est un petit peu un peu
trop un peu forte du moins car on est
c'est une économie des mobilités vous
savez aujourd'hui surtout le tourisme
donc ça nous paraissait un peu juste de
ne pas pouvoir se dépasser des 100 km il
est évident que cette saison on aura pas
d'entente habilité ici les gens ne perd
pas d'argent
c'était c'est un exploit on peut pas si
vous voulez après ce choc qui est
inhumain mettre en doute nos entreprises
et se dire qu'on va retrouver d'abord
quel présentation au bâton à voir et en
même temps il va y avoir un choc
émotionnel qui va se pour le moment on
est un peu aseptisé par ce choc mais le
et évidemment il y aura un choc
émotionnel et psychologique qui va
suivre et autres annonces attendues
celles concernant les écoles elles
seront toutes ouvertes enjoint
l'ensemble des collèges en auront en
zone verte avec une réouverture
progressive cette fois pour les zones
oranges et côté le ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'ensemble des
collèges vont désormais ouvrir ce soit
en zone verte ou en zone orange
en zone verte cela signifie donc que
l'on n'ajoute la 4e et la troisième
après la 6e et la cinquième qui ont déjà
ouvert donc l'ensemble des classes sont
ouvertes en zone verte en zone orange
nous allons accueillir en priorité les
élèves de 6e et de 5e et si les
conditions matérielles sont réunies les
élèves des autres niveaux pourront
ensuite être accueilli par benjamin amar
enseignants porte parole cgt du val de
marne les français voudraient au
contraire que la rentrée soit reportée
en septembre c'est son avis c'est
surtout d'une malhonnêteté incroyable
c'est à dire que c'est pas les familles
qui le souhaitent c'est jean michel
blanquer
et vous savez on a tous les sondages
d'opinion les sondages d'opinion
montrent que les français sont ultra
majoritairement contre la réouverture
des écoles bien conscient que les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire ne sont
pas fournis donc faire croire que c'est
qu'ils répondent à comment dire aux
desiderata des familles c'est à hurler
de rire c'est exactement la verse
les français voudraient que comme en
italie comme en espagne comme dans
l'état de new york
les écoles la rentrée soit reportée en
septembre à et cette décision elle est
complètement aberrante et elle est
marquée par un entêtement de plus en
plus absurde et quatre jours avant de
regoûter à certaines libertés le bilan
du coronavirus dans l'hexagone continue
de baisser selon les chiffres de la
direction générale de la santé en compte
soixante six nouveaux décès à l'hôpital
en 24 heures au total 28 mille six cent
soixante deux personnes sont mortes
depuis le début de l'épidémie
les résultats sont bons a précisé
edouard philippe lors de son allocution
tout en rappelant l'importance
évidemment des gestes barrières et du
port du masque
toufik verbal ex-collaborateurs
d'olivier vers ans est visé par une
enquête pour trafic d'influencé il est
soupçonné d'avoir cherché à la mi mars à
positionner une offre de masques ffp2
auprès du ministère de la santé afin de
toucher une commission
l'enquète est en cours contre le mis en
cause qui a reconnu les faits et détails
avec money amont dès lors c'est une
enquête qui embarrasse le ministère de
la santé qui permet d'en savoir un peu
plus sur les agissements de certains
collaborateurs en coulisses tewfik
derbal ex collaborateur d'olivier vers
ans est visé par une enquête pour trafic
d'influencé après avoir tenté de toucher
une commission sur une livraison de
masques ffp2 d'une société
d'import-export alors que le pays
connaissait une pénurie en la matière
tout commence en mars alors que la
pandémie de kovy 19 se répand en europe
une société française d'import export
avec la chine se tourne vers ses
fournisseurs locaux et trouvant des
bouchers des masques ffp2 la société
entre donc en contact avec tewfik derbal
l'ex collaborateur du ministre de la
santé
d'après médiapart le 16 mars l'ex
assistant parlementaire répond
rapidement aux sollicitations de la
société je suis en lien avec la personne
qui gère cette situation au sein du
ministère
je voulais savoir comment vous procédez
habituellement avec les apporteurs
d'affaires au lendemain de cette
conversation durban en dit que les
autorités sont intéressés par les
masques proposés et formule une demande
je vous joins un contrat d'apporteur
d'affaires accompagnée d'un avenant afin
de valider notre collaboration
vous n'avez plus qu'à compléter la
commission en pourcentage qui me revient
et signer le contrat et l'avenant il
faut préciser qu'un million de masques
étaient proposées et d'après les
éléments récoltés par mediapart m figues
des rebelles a réclamé 2 % du prix sur
chaque masque vendu la société lui
explique que ce n'est pas l'usagé en
matière d'import export car cela
impliquerait une hausse du prix du
masque le faisant passer de 2 euros 60
pièces à 2,066 un contrat est donc
proposé indiquant à théophile derbal qui
touchera une commission
interrogé par mediapart celui ci nie
d'abord puis devant les haies
en présenter fini par concéder qu'il
s'était dit pourquoi pas expliquant que
la société avait proposé cette
commission je lui ai pas dit au fait moi
je veux une commission je connais des
gens par téléphone il nous a fait part
d'un possible remerciements si la
transaction avait lieu j'avais déjà ma
société j'ai dit pourquoi pas je vais
seulement souhaité faire les choses en
bonne et due forme en proposant un
contrat
il m'a ouvert une porte automatique mans
j'y suis entré pourtant selon les
éléments récoltés par mediapart c'est
bien derbal qui aborde le sujet de cette
commission
et c'est encore lui qui transmet un
contrat d'apporteur d'affaires à remplir
et réclame avec insistance 2% du prix
sur chaque masque vendus selon mediapart
le contrat a été signé entre les deux
parties mais la transaction n'a jamais
eu lieu
le mis en cause a depuis reconnu les
faits et d'après bfmtv tewfik derbal a
été placé en garde à vue puis relâchés
de son côté ollier vers ans a indiqué
que cette histoire ne le concernait pas
le parquet de paris a donc ouvert une
enquête préliminaire pour trafic
d'influencé commis par un particulier en
délit passible de 5 ans d'emprisonnement
et 500000 euros damende à une relance à
750 milliards d'euros pour l'union
européenne la commission de bruxelles a
présenté son plan pour répondre à la
crise du coronavirus il fait la part
belle aux subventions et favorise les
pays les plus touchés comme l'italie et
l'espagne
ce plan qui s'inspire en grande partie
des propositions françaises et
allemandes petit l'emporter à l'adhésion
des plus réfractaires comme les pays-bas
ou l'autriche est il à la hauteur de la
récession qui nous est en voie cela avec
à l'économiste jacques sapir
si on compare avec ce que font par
exemple les autres grands pays que ce
soit la chine où que ce soit les états
unis et bien les sommes qui sont tant
que sont très faibles pour l'union
européenne on est actuellement autour de
3 % du pib alors qu'on est entre 7 et
10% pour le plan de relance seulement je
parle pas des les plans d'accompagnement
de la crise les pour le plan de relance
mans on est entre 7 et 10% du pib en
chine et aux états unis
alors oui on voit bien il ya un gros
problème maintenant le plan franco
allemand qui a été présentée le lundi 18
mai eh bien il propose 540 milliards ce
qui n'est pas rien évidemment puisque ça
viendrait s'ajouter aux 500 milliards
qui était déjà prévu mais ses 540
milliards eh bien il va s'agir
essentiellement de transferts
budgétaires puisque c'est de l'argent
que la commission de bruxelles
les vrais directement sur les marchés le
problème c'est qu'évidemment cette
proposition a provoqué une crispation
chez les pays du nord ce qu'on appelle
les quatre frugaux la hollande la suède
le danemark vraiment et l'autriche et
que évidemment aidé on est parti dans
une dans un cycle de négociations on
peut même parler qu'on est parti pour un
nouveau cycle des faux semblants
la commission européenne a fait mercredi
dernier a fait des propositions qui
d'ailleurs s'inspire assez largement des
propositions qui avaient été faits par
la france et l'allemagne
là encore il s'agirait d'un emprunt que
prendrait directement à la commission
alors le point qui est un petit peu
important le point qui tranche
peut-être dans cette province dans cette
proposition de la commission par rapport
à la proposition franco allemand c'est
que d'avoir les plus importantes
grosso modo 750 milliards mais elle est
divisée en deux il ya d'une part 500
milliards qui seraient en réalité des
fonds budgétaires et là on retrouve la
mécanique qui était celle du plan franco
allemand et puis il ya 250 milliards qui
seraient plutôt des prêts accordés aux
différents pays alors le point sur
lequel il faut peut-être bien revenir
c'est le fait que la commission exige en
réalité que les priorités politiques
qu'elle a fixés en particulier la
transition écologique ce qu'on appelle
le fameux green deal que ses priorités
politiques soient respectés et d'autre
part il est clair qu'elle veut
avant c'est sur cette idée de
mutualisation des dettes alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça ça veut dire que il
n'ya pas là de deux points de compromis
entre ce que propose des quatre offres
hugo est ce que propose la commission
que donc les débats vont être houleux et
qu'il faudra de nombreuses réunions du
conseil européen pour pouvoir avancer
sur cette question si tenté que l'on
avance si vous regardez grosso modo les
sommes qui sont en cause avec le plan
franco allemand on est grosso modo
autour de 1000 milliards d'euros avec le
plan de la commission 12150 si on
regarde le plan de relance qui a été
déjà acté
aux etats unis ses 2300 milliards
or l'économie américaine elle est en
fait plus petit que l'économie de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne dont déjà là il ya un
problème tout à fait évident et je passe
évidemment sur la question des
négociations qui seront comme je voulais
dit extrêmement difficile en fait la
solution qui aurait été la plus
rationnelle et certainement la plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre
c'était la solution qui consistait à
dire aux pays-bas écoutez vous faites
les plans dont vous avez besoin on va
pas regarder ce que vous faites est
votre endettement et bien c'est
directement la banque centrale
européenne qui le reprend oui mais
malheureusement il y à l'arrêt du 5 mai
de la cour de carros rond qui est venu
d'une certaine manière faire capoter
je dirais tout cette belle mécanique et
c'est peut-être pour ça que l'on est
aujourd'hui rentré dans cette logique de
propositions qui devront être âprement
discutés dans plusieurs conseils
européens
et donald trump doit signer d'une minute
à l'autre un traité visant les réseaux
sociaux cette décision intervient
quelques heures après que le président
américain est menacée de réguler ou de
fermer les entreprises du secteur retour
sur la relation entre le président
américain et twitter en images
[Musique]
oh
en
twitter s'immisce maintenant dans
l'élection présidentielle de 2020 ils
disent que ma déclaration sur le vote
par correspondance qui va conduire à une
corruption et une fraude massive est
incorrect en se basant sur une
vérification des faits par cnn fausses
nouvelles et l'amazone washington post
twitter étouffe complètement la liberté
d'expression et moi en tant que
président je ne permettrai pas que cela
se produise
[Musique]
on
et l instant donald trump vient de
signer un décret visant à limiter la
protection dont bénéficie twitter et
facebook pas d'autres informations pour
le moment nous y reviendrons évidemment
dans nos prochaines éditions en
attendant écoutez l'analyse de caleb
maupin journaliste politique pour rta
america sur ce thème
twitter étiquette
les déclarations du président sous
critères titan qu'à une disons qu'on ne
sont pas fondées et remettez en question
sur qui la filme bien sûr tonight rome
et la maison blanche selon lui sa prime
time en donald trump et beaucoup de
conservateurs au sénat d'une ce qu'il ya
une pression aux états unis depuis les
élections 2016 il ya beaucoup d'efforts
afin de contrôler les informations
qu'ils allaient à l'encontre plus
réussies du discours libéral dans les
pays occidentaux capitaliste et que ces
efforts avaient mené un billet politique
qui a contre les conservateurs aux états
unis il a effectivement évoqué la
possibilité de former twitter mais cela
serait assez complexe
suivant la constitution américaine le
département de la justice américain
étudie le la question de savoir si
google apple twitter ou facebook fonte à
l'encontre des lois antimonopoles union
états unis
car n'est pas vraiment de compétition
dans ce domaine et si le travail en tant
que monopole alors il n'y a aucun aucune
façon de pouvoir les décrire en tant que
compagnie qu'entreprises privées qui
sont utilisé cet argument pour dire
qu'il s'agissait de censure deuxième
journée de violences consécutives à
minneapolis aux états unis après le
meurtre d'un afro-américain par la
police était lundi dernier
depuis la ville du minnesota ne cesse de
son réseau des émeutes qui touchent
aussi d'autres villes du pays pierre qui
savent yverdon depuis deux jours
minneapolis est le théâtre de scènes
violentes entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants
les mouvements de protestation contre le
meurtre de george floyd et 46 cents par
des policiers se multiplient
le maire et le gouverneur du minnesota
tente de calmer la situation
s'il vous plaît minneapolis nous ne
pouvons pas laisser la tragédie engendré
plus de tragédies la zone le long du lac
est devenue dangereuse
nous demandons votre aide pour maintenir
la paix ce soir la situation près de
l'extrémité y à watts à minneapolis est
devenue une situation extrêmement
dangereuse pour la sécurité de tous
veuillez quitter la zone et autoriser
les pompiers et les ambulanciers
paramédicaux à se rendre sur les lieux
c'est donc une vidéo de l'arrestation
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux qui met
le feu aux poudres en début de semaine
on y voit john floyd agonisant sur le
sol sous le genou d'un policier et
supplier pour qu'on lui laisse la vie
sauve
la colère voilà donc le sentiment qui
règne aujourd'hui dans les rues de
minneapolis c'est le pire passage à
tabac de la police de tous les temps et
je dis toujours que je ne peux rien voir
de pire que les coûts de rodney king
c'est pire que rodney king dans le
contexte de cet homme souffrant pendant
9 minutes
nous devons nous rassembler rester unis
ce n'est pas normal
nous sommes en 2020 le virus nous tue la
police nous tue le gouvernement n'aide
personne
pour l'avocat de la famille de josh
floyd rien ne peut justifier un tel
comportement
si vous avez un téléphone portable vous
le prenez vous réglez votre chronomètre
sur neuf minutes vous vous asseyez vous
laisser le temps passé et à ce moment là
vous imaginez quelqu'un avec son genou
contre votre coup alors que vous vous
débattez pour pouvoir respirer alors que
personne ne fait rien pour que vous
puissiez respirer et bien tout ça ce
sont les dernières minutes de la vie de
georges floyd en un mot c'est un meurtre
il n'y a rien qui justifie cela
en ce qui concerne le gouvernement
justement à donald trump lui aussi a
réagi le président américain demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête
à ma demande le fbi et le ministère de
la justice ont déjà entamé une enquête
sur la mort très tristes et tragiques de
john floyd au minnesota
c'est donc une affaire qui en rappellent
d'autres aux états unis depuis plusieurs
années les victimes noires sous les
coups de policier blanc se multiplient
aujourd'hui les quatre policiers
responsables de la mort de georges floyd
ont été renvoyés les autorités locales à
vous aujourd'hui vouloir mettre tout en
oeuvre pour faire la lumière sur cette
terrible tragédie est à la fin de cette
édition merci d'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous avec l'actualité de me
mettre 7 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée